[Music]
10.
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
do
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
what is going on everyone happy saturday
thank you for joining me on the c4d live
stream thanks for hanging out with me
all
you guys are the best um man it has been
an intense
two weeks man most of you guys know at
this point
that uh that i left corridor i left my
job at corridor
to pursue this to pursue all this full
time
and i couldn't be more excited like i
love those guys over at corridor and
they
they actually really helped me um you
know
get as many eyes on this as possible so
i really appreciate the corridor boys i
freaking love them
and we're hanging out all the time so
don't you guys even worry
i'll be in videos here and there um
as you guys probably already know but
look y'all today we
are building out a motorcycle all right
so basically i have for you guys
this blockout all right and the story
behind this
is i want to be able to make another
super high quality render
um like a really cool environment and
this motorcycle is a part of it
and the only way that i can model this
motorcycle i don't want to just download
one
um because i feel i feel like part of me
part of me just wants to create this on
my own you know so really what i want to
do here is model my own motorcycle
and you guys can join me if you're using
cinema 4d obviously i'm in c4d
or if you're using blender or whatever
the heck you guys are using
please join me on this um it's a blast
it's gonna be a lot of work but it's
gonna be very fun
and it's gonna pay off um so we're gonna
be focusing
today on the stream we're gonna be
focusing on building this complex model
um as a block out first the blockout is
so important
to anything that's complex all right
because
if you start getting right into the
details of something like if i got right
into the details of my little sam porter
bridges guy right here
i started detailing all out all these
little pieces here like it'd just take
me forever i'd want to block it out you
know
and this is a machine uh motorcycle so
for me it's easier to just start with
blocks and then get deep more detailed
more detail more detailed you don't want
to give up
immediately right in the beginning so
you want to just kind of like do your
broad strokes to your sketch
that's exactly what we're doing today
building up that block out now once we
get
this block out done alright we're gonna
hop right into
the art review um the challenge winners
of
the weekly challenge i told you guys in
the last video
we're doing basically everyone the
prompt was to model a sentimental item
you got to model it from scratch this
week and oh my god guys we got
325 submissions that's
two-thirds more than like usual
basically uh
it's the most submissions we've ever had
and i'm just very excited to get into it
i'm gonna show you guys the winners
my five favorite and i'm gonna show you
like 30 honorable mentions because
there's just too many good ones
but y'all um before we get into it
we gotta talk to our sponsor today it's
gonna be
skillshare so i got a little little
video for you all to check out
definitely click that link in the
description it helps me out um and it's
two free weeks of skillshare free for
you guys so let me let me tell you a
little bit about it
this week's stream is brought to you by
our friends over at skillshare
skillshare is an online learning
community for creatives like you guys
who are looking to up their game
grow their value and learn a new skill
now it doesn't matter if you're a
beginner
intermediate or advanced on your journey
you can learn
anything here on skillshare at any level
and any
schedule type too because these classes
come in bite-size little chunks
sometimes 5-10 minutes and it'll allow
you to fit it into your very busy
schedule
all right so first i got to shout out
this incredible artist this guy is don
mupassi known as
visual don he's an incredible artist
he's going to teach you guys how to make
a looping city animation in c4d
and after effects this guy is awesome
the work he puts out in c4d is
incredible and i know you guys are going
to learn a ton with his tutorials on
skillshare next
up i know we got some blender folks up
in here so i don't want to forget about
you guys blender is a free program
it is a fantastic program if you guys
are looking to dive in and learn how to
do stuff for free
and there's a ton of great tutorials on
skillshare for blender and this one here
is an intro to modeling so if you guys
are trying to
learn more about how modeling works what
it is this is a great way to start
for anyone trying to do this for free
and finally for anyone trying to bite
off more than they can chew
there is a ridiculous 11 hour course on
how to make a game
here on skillshare it's a fantastic
course lots to learn here
and unreal engine is again it's free
guys so check out this fun course on
skillshare it's a good time so as a
skillshare member you guys get unlimited
access to regularly updated premium
content
for less than 9.99 a month for a yearly
subscription and to the first thousand
people who click the link in the
description
i got you guys with a free trial of a
skillshare premium
membership you guys are going to learn
something new you're going to grow
you're going to get past the competition
and it also helps me out too it helps me
do more of these live streams so click
the link in the description and start
learning
all right y'all all right yo you guys
ready to start learning
i'm excited um but yeah if you guys want
to help out definitely click the link in
the description you all got two weeks
for free
on me and skillshare uh get your learn
on if you guys want to dive into more
stuff
helps me out and help you guys out too
you guys will get your get your learn on
um elrie talon thank you for the super
chat i appreciate you
yeah you're working in blender but you
don't know your hockeys dude you gotta
learn your hot keys man
learn those freaking hot keys that's the
way you gotta fly through your program
um like i equate it to basically
when you guys are learning something new
anytime you're on your your educational
journey as
as most of you guys are right now when
you first start a program
you you're stuck you're like stuck in
quicksand you're crawling through your
through your program but then as you get
better right and you learn your hotkeys
and stuff then you can start wading
through this quickstand and eventually
you get to the point where you can start
running and then you can start flying
and then you're like
god mode and you're just like doing
everything because you know it all
but it takes a minute to get there right
it takes maybe a couple of years to get
there so learning your hotkeys is a way
you can fly through that
um and derek thank you for the super
chat you guys are awesome thank you so
much
it all helps out there's like so much
that goes into prepping these streams
before
i get this thing live and going it's a
lot it's a lot of work so the super
chats are
very much appreciated thank you guys so
much
but without further ado y'all let's get
into it
let's build this motorcycle so
i don't have the motorcycle built
obviously because you know
it's gonna be a lot of work but this is
the block out this is what i made
um this morning to make my thumbnail
essentially for this video because you
all got to figure out what the heck
we're doing
um and the idea here let me pull up
pureref so pureref
is a fantastic program and i use this
for reference imagery so i'm going to go
ahead and load
let's see i'll tell you guys a little
bit about the piece of art i'm trying to
make here
that the motorcycle kind of plays into
so basically
a few years ago i went hiking in
utah it was the arches national park and
we found this place called uh
what is it called um shoot
it's it's in canyonlands and it's called
false
kiva yeah false kiva is the name of this
place i think it's spelled
uh f-a-l-s-e and then kiva is k-i-v-a
and it's basically if you guys have seen
uh
[Music]
have if you guys have seen avatar the
last airbender like the southern air
temple where it's like underneath
the mountain and in like a little cave
that's basically what this
is so this is a panorama i took
and i'm standing basically you see these
like
these stones these stacked stones well
that is
this this is me lying down in this
little circle
area here and it looks out to this
amazing
uh this amazing view here so what i want
to do is create this environment
um i want to spice it up though with a
couple like
fossils in the background you know some
like breath of the wild style
fossils back here like huge ones
kind of like this you know so there's a
lot going into this
render that i want to do but it
definitely takes place this is kind of
similar to the angle i want
um and and while i'm not going to be
building out this whole environment on
the stream
i'm going to be building the motorcycle
that's going to be a part of it because
basically
i want to have a campfire two characters
a road that leads down to this valley
that shows uh that giant like fallen
colossal thing
and then there's gonna be two
motorcycles parked on the left side here
and that's what i'm gonna be blocking
out on the stream today
is one of those motorcycles and
backstory on the motorcycle so
in little tokyo um i saw this dude
this guy right here he is amazing
because look at this bike
it's the craziest bike i've ever seen
it's pieced together with duct tape and
and like zip ties and stuff um like
there's wires hanging out of every
every angle everything's like ratchet
strapped down even his kickstand is like
you know cinched down with little metal
pieces um
and i just loved this bike i didn't know
what i wanted to do with it
i just needed to take that picture and
this was probably like
four years ago or something at this
point and i just loved it i loved how
crazy it looked and how
pieced together it looked it reminded me
of like a miyazaki studio ghibli kind of
uh
kind of vehicle so this is what i'm
gonna be blocking out today
on the stream jay siren you're not
late you ain't late we just begun these
things go for a minute all right
and currently y'all we just broke the
record 940 people
in the live stream right now that's
incredible you guys are awesome
thank you for the support love you guys
um it's only getting better from here
y'all it is only getting better from
here i'm so excited
to spend my full time um to this youtube
channel to this freaking
uh to this whole thing man like i want
to do a movie
i'm working with a writer to do a movie
um i'm working on some short films
and i'm doing some vfx education for you
guys so it's gonna be awesome
all right so let's dive in we got a
reference
i'm using pure ref that's the program um
to pull up my reference imagery and this
is gonna be with me for
the entire process here so i'm just
going to get this down
i might pull it off to the other to the
other monitor here but for now i think
we can just
probably place it right in our like
little render view that i've set up here
and we'll use this as an example so to
get the angle of this picture
perfect you can see here that the angle
is pretty spot-on
i used what is called the camera
calibration tool in c4d and it's pretty
sweet it lets you like
line up an image um where is it i got
rid of my background
yeah it basically allows you to line up
an image um or get rid of this thing
yeah and then like you go in and you add
all of your little lines you tell it
what's the x-axis the y-axis
so that's how i got that going but i'm
going to start i'm going to start from
scratch on this guys
um i'm just going to i'm going to delete
literally everything
and we're going to get into it here so
we want to do a block out of this
all right the block out is going to
allow us to
essentially start adding the details the
block out is the foundation
on which we build the details this
is insane if i i'm looking at this i'm
getting overwhelmed already how the heck
am i going to model and create this
thing
um it's going to be a lot i mean
literally the other night i was thinking
like
do i even want to do this like should i
just download a model
you know from turbosquid or something
and
uh i think this is the way to go i think
i need to do this
so let's see what we can do here
for whatever reason the wacom tablet has
got this
update that is killing me so y'all bear
with me there might be some technical
difficulties
you know that that's how it is when you
live stream 970 y'all we we are close to
that 1000 mark
i'm at the i don't think i have any
party poppers left 984
very close 994. oh my god
y'all 1013 people
that is a new record thank you guys for
making that happen holy crap that's
insane
a thousand people in the stream that's
what's up
all right let's get working because we
got a thousand people doing this
and they're like yo get to it already
all right so look
primitives that's what we're dealing
with that's your spheres your cones your
cubes and your tubes
all right we're gonna make a tube and
these are gonna be our wheels right here
so let's uh let's set that to plus
z all right and
i'm gonna make that editable actually no
before i do that
n b that's gonna be your shortcut to see
the polygons
the primo arts yo thank you for the
super chat much appreciated
your name's kamal thank you for making
the awesome content do you ever 3d print
the things you model
dude i've never 3d printed anything um
maybe one day
but for now i just like you know putting
stuff on the screen
i really enjoy it but thanks for thanks
for enjoying the content man i
appreciate you
so we can add subdivisions and all this
later
um so i don't think we need any of those
segments
let's get the inner radius up a little
bit
outer radius yeah sure and the height
will just kind of
scrunch down to get to that tire size
hit c we'll make it editable
and i want to get the gizmo on the
ground i want to i want to line this
thing up so it's sitting right on the
ground
but instead of eyeballing it basically i
can hit l
get this gizmo on the ground but that's
still eyeballing it
so what i use is the axis center tool
this tool right here
and i'll slide the y-axis all the way to
the bottom
that moves the axis all the way down and
now i know i can just zero that out
and it's sitting right on the ground
plane
boom no guesswork involved
okay control drag get our other wheel
going here
and we can you know we can feel this out
as we go
t is for scale i'll make that back tire
just like a little bit bigger probably
and
hmm how are we going to do this here
what do we want to start
with now we can go into a little bit
more detail on the tire
you know we might be able to do
basically something like this where we
let's let's change the axis back to the
center point bam
and if you hold control basically you'll
create a new primitive
in the place of this old one um
y'all oh my goodness first off johnny
boz up in the house good to see you dude
thank you for the super chat he says
happy saturday motorcycle hype we're
getting down
um good to see you man johnny boz has
been a long
time friend a long time fan of the
channel uh we've met at multiple vidcons
challenged a mario kart race beat him
very badly
and he had to do you know some some
publicly embarrassing things
i think he has a video to it somewhere
on his channel pretty funny
uh and then redbeast vfx man thank you
so much for that super chat
very very kind of you he says hey clint
uh
you've been a huge inspiration for me as
i've taught myself c4d excited that i'm
able to use your
your tutorials to help me on my journey
can i maybe ask what genre you hope to
make your feature
oh man that's a good question um well
i'm glad that i was able to teach you a
thing or two i hope i can continue to do
that in the future here
what genre do i want to do for my
feature i well here's the thing i love
so many different genres i love action i
love comedy
um i love drama
uh there's some good horror movies out
there but really it comes down to me
action comedy and storytelling it's
gotta be about the story and the
characters first and foremost
so what we're working on now i don't i
don't know if i want to say too much
about it but
there's gonna be there's gonna be heart
there's gonna be drama
there's gonna be action there's gonna be
comedy
um there's gonna be a lot of good stuff
in it so i'm very excited i'm working
with a very
talented writer his name is nate davis
nathan graham davis
he's been writing uh for years like he
my focus on vfx and directing is his
focus but for writing so like
i can't do this one without him we're
teaming up on it it's gonna be awesome
um wow arcboard oh my god the super chat
geez man thank you so much he says
thanks for keeping me inspired the last
few months you got me through some tough
times last year and i wanted to thank
you for everything i finally landed a
job in 3d design
and i'm super pumped can't wait to see
you kill this here dude congratulations
on your new job man that is awesome 3d
design that's so much fun
you get to just make stuff all day get
paid to do it
that's super sick man congratulations
thank you for that super chat that is
very generous of you
uh man we got more diego thank you for
the super chat shout outs man
that's great and uh i
i'd muh i don't know if i'm pronouncing
that right apologies
but it uh says much love thank you for
sharing this stuff
absolutely i got you guys okay
so like i was saying hold control
y'all hold ctrl to make stuff
within your stuff so let's see i want to
make a cylinder in here
and let's make that plus z as well so
if i didn't hold ctrl it'd just be you
know right down here
and but i want it in the center point so
you gotta hold ctrl to get that
and spawn it right up in that tube
so i'm gonna make it editable and just
take this down and make some wheel
pieces
you know roughly something like that and
we can scale this down but not affect
the z so uncheck the z
and then you know you can scale this
down like this
and there's a lot of detail going in
there but i think that's going to be
good enough for us for our block out
there
um and this back piece let's see let's
just control drag this guy
here as well and
hit s to snap to whatever
you have selected that feels about right
to me
amazing let's group our stuff
alt g will group it
this is our front wheel
and alt g to group it
this is our back wheel
keep yourself organized it's going to
get crazy i promise you it's going to
get crazy
make sure you save your work please save
your work
and i'm saving iterations so i can go
back to previous work here
so i really want to do a solid job
of blocking this out unlike the
thumbnail that was very quick very fast
um so i want to make sure that i'm
really setting myself up to save time
here
now all these pipes and parts and all
this and
wires and stuff that's gonna live and
kind of grow off of this base stuff that
we're setting down i think you guys get
the point
so you know there's a seat
involved here let me let me do this one
last time
because it's going to be glitchy on me
like as you can see here
just like that um
[Music]
perfect
all right and then we'll we'll just
leave it at that
right there
all right
what are we going to do next here so we
got exhaust pipes
we have the chair let's see if we can't
build out
the fuel tank so the fuel tank piece
let's see if we can do that
um simon what up um
nft thoughts i'm on foundation hard to
sell nfts i think are awesome
they are uh allowing artists to make a
living
creating the art they love um i
personally
have i've sold one piece um and it went
really really well
and i'm excited to do more yeah i think
it's very cool
so yeah let's do this
tank piece all right so it's this piece
right here
this little like fuel tank right
so i'm just gonna make this cube
editable and let's
build this thing out all right so it
looks like it tapers
um the front and the back so kl we're
gonna make a cut here
and let's see if we can't
move this line down so w is gonna switch
between world and local orientation and
that's
that's going to help you all the time
we'll get these guys we'll hit t and
we'll scale them down
something like that and you guys see how
i'm doing this right
we're building out this block out
um uh
sooth sonata thank you for the super
chat much appreciated
for the coffee i got my kombucha right
here ready to go
when it's time all right
um let's maybe ctrl drag
to make a new geometry so you see that
control drag will make new geometry
and we'll scale that down and that's
that's kind of
your block out for this thing here now
it
kind of kind of tapers in
on the sides here and i'm just i'm going
by eye i'm not really
i'm not really going too hard on this
again w is for your world and local
orientation
and let's see
oh is that that off no that's correct
okay
let's take these guys and we'll scale
these guys in
because it's kind of angled you see you
guys see the way it's angled in like
this
a little bit like that
and that feels that feels close
that's not bad again this is a blockout
right so another thing we can do
let's see maybe maybe this comes down a
little bit
i just want to get the feeling and the
shape of this thing
and then the whole thing if i go to
model mode right there
maybe the whole thing will scale up
um hit t and scale that guy up like that
and we're building this thing out so
you know we can use this later basically
to
you know throw it into a subdivision
surface and then
kl is going to be your loop edge and you
can toggle back and forth
with q and we can just start like
sharpening these points but we're not
there yet you know
we're certainly not there yet but this
will be
you know the process when we get into it
later and we start going for the detail
um you know most of you guys are here
probably from my last video where i
showed you guys
the subdivision modeling process
more of an overview and then i have a
whole
a whole live stream on modeling those
bone phones which
i don't have with me right now but it's
that's that subdivision process
very fun makes your stuff look really
good really clean uh matthias yo
thank you thank you so much for the
super chat that's awesome man
he says clint i'm hyped for the stream
and i was wondering if you will make
this whole scenery project
a video series on your channel or stream
only a video project i wonder if you
make this whole
scenery project a video on your channel
i'm not quite sure um
exactly what you mean by that the whole
scenery project you mean like
the creation of this of this scene yeah
oh yeah dude for sure
like i have to live stream every week
anyway so
my i might as well live stream like the
art that i'm trying to make so
to me that sounds like a win-win it's
just a matter if you guys
are down for that um if you guys are
like yeah this is boring i don't enjoy
it
then maybe we'll figure something else
out but i'm going to be doing this stuff
anyway
all right so the seat we have a seat
piece that we need to model so
if again if you go to model mode this
little top left box
select the model you want hold ctrl and
make a primitive it's going to spawn
that primitive right there
um on basically
yeah what's the best way to explain this
i think you guys get it right if i were
to
rotate this thing all crazy and move it
off in some crazy direction
and i hold ctrl and make that cube there
it's going to be spawned with the right
attributes the right position rotation
and all that stuff
that's why it's very handy just holding
control very simple
all right so now i want to build out the
seat okay so the seat
i'm just gonna make this cube editable
and we're gonna crunch it down
and let's go to edge mode kl
to make those loop cuts and if you hold
shift it can snap on these different
pieces
i'm go right down the middle and add one
right
so we have two perfectly spaced cuts
i'll select them both hit t for scale
and move them out to the side
wonderful okay from here i just want to
extrude these little bottom pieces for
the seat all right so d
will be your extrude and something like
that
kl
we're gonna need kl here here for
looks like we need to let's see
right down the middle right down the
middle i'm just thinking about this
shape here so i take these edges here
and
move them back i'm looking right here
at the seat sorry at the seat
and let's go ahead and maybe grab
these guys to get the shape of this
thing right
kind of comes up and around like that
yeah and then it tapers in the back
as well so let's grab
these guys these guys and we'll pull
them back like this
and it's lower than the gas tank so we
need to
bring this thing down to about here and
it's kind of right
up on that gas tank too
very nice very nice are you guys doing
all right give me a thumbs up if you
guys are enjoying this video give me a
smiley face if you
are following along and modeling
something yourself
paul crawford yo thank you so much i
appreciate you man that's a very
generous super chat as well
thank you thank you he says you've been
watching my vid since cardboard warfare
man that's like
11 years ago um uh oh
here comes here comes the chat train i
gotta read the super chat
um he says you corridor and freddie were
big influences on me becoming a
filmmaker i recently started getting in
a 3d space
in blender and i'm loving it so far dude
yes man congratulations
welcome to the 3d world it is a
wonderful world
the reason i got into it was because i
realized that i can create
anything that i can imagine if i'm
technically good enough
so that gave me the the the drive
to learn 3d because i want to make
movies
and if i can make the stuff i see in my
head look photo real
then i can make any movie i want and
make it seem real so
that's like that's why i'm getting into
it you know um but all right y'all are
freaking
having a good time that is what's up all
right all right
and shout outs hey shout outs to our
moderators we got ronin visual
uh sadamante darren winkle uh
mdk and my god
am i forgetting someone sipo yeah we got
some moderators up in here thank you
guys for
for helping out um they're on the
discord server making it happen this
week was crazy i'll get into it later
when we when we get into our art review
but um
but this week was insane moderate
moderators were working
around the clock to make sure that uh
the weekly challenge went as smoothly as
possible
all right let's maybe widen the seat out
a little bit
so i might just do a cut knife tool
that's k k hold shift bam
write down the line there oh but we need
to
you see that here
ctrl y you see how it just cut on the
top
we don't want that we want it to cut
through everything so you just want to
check
where is it visible only yeah so just
hold shift bam try again
and now it's going through everything
there all right
so we'll grab these these little edges
here
boom boom and
[Music]
technically technically
we want all this stuff so hit zero grab
the points
all these points right here let's grab
all this hit t for scale
and blue widen it out just a little bit
something like that and same for
same for this here
boom we'll get those in close
that's your seat amazing
it's looking good and that's gonna sit
right over top
basically
maybe it's a little intense maybe that's
a little intense zero
that's gonna be your like rectangular
selection tool and it's gonna cut
through anything
um any polygons that you can't see
it's gonna find them and it's gonna get
them all right so that's our seat
but the seat kind of comes up in the
front too
so maybe what we'll do is make another
cut
let's make another cut bam right down
here
and let's grab
all of these points and move them
up just a bit yeah riptide yo thank you
for the super chat
appreciate your man he says stoke for
the new path i'm the guy that made a vid
of you singing on my channel what's the
best way to reach
you for business stuff good question
yeah um
so the best way to reach me for business
stuff will probably be
um my business email which is
uh punisherdirect gmail.com
for business inquiries only otherwise
hit me up on discord guys
i'm there i am there
let's save save save save save your
stuff
okay um
i feel like the wheel is a little close
back wheel
or his little far because that basically
comes
right up to there
and then we're gonna build out
basically like the top seat piece
which is technically part of this bottom
seat so
let's name our stuff again we gotta name
our stuff
seat and gas tank
let's grab these polys here
hold ctrl to make new ones move them up
and then move them back here like this
maybe actually no maybe here's what we
can do actually
we'll just hit up we'll select those
we'll hit up that's going to break up
that's the way i think of it up is up
up boom that makes new polygons
that you can move and do your thing on
um let's go ahead and make this a little
thicker this is our back seat
all right we want a little bit of
cushion
you know and maybe same for the seed we
can give it a little bit of cushion hit
u
y that's gonna be gross selection
boom we can move those guys up just a
little bit
and for whatever reason we need to yeah
we need to cap this here
so that is going to be let's see this is
our back seat
uh md like medical doctor patch and
holes that's the way i think of it
md patch those holes and then k
k for the knife tool
and we're just gonna get those right
there
awesome vanda tours thank you for the
super chat
you all are awesome thank you thank you
he says you're a sound designer
photographer videographer and you
inspired me to start looking in a cg
your teaching style is very approachable
man that means a lot
i'm glad i'm very glad cg man it's such
a fun world
you can do whatever you want again given
that you know
how to technically maneuver the program
so that's why i want to be able to you
know teach you guys how to do it
to show you how i do my thing um and my
way is not
the best way it's not the worst way it's
just a way
um so if it speaks to y'all
that's cool that's cool with me all
right so the seat the back seat
um it goes to i don't know based off
that bottom reference image i know it's
tiny
i'm guessing it goes to about where it
is
yeah that feels good um
[Music]
maybe you can go a little further or
something
boom something like that
now we have some water cans
and we have a like uh
basically a like a storage container on
the back
and all of that is kind of sitting on
top of this seat piece
okay so what we're gonna do here is save
our work
and let's go ahead and rough these in so
in model mode
let's go ahead and select oh so you have
the back seat you see how the gizmo on
the back seat is way over here
if you hit this little this tool right
here this is the center axis 2 tool
boom it's going to center it and that's
going to be the same for all of this
stuff it's going to center the axis
to the object you have and it's very
handy i use it all the time
car keys oh yes there you go
love you have fun all right
um cesar what's up dude yo thank you for
the super chat
i appreciate you as always man uh he
says you're excited for new challenge
reviews the first time i participated
thanks for sharing your knowledge
it's easier absolutely thank you for
joining i know it's a lot of work for
you all throughout the week
so i think it's a really really cool
incentive to
bite off little challenges every week
to help you guys get better at what
you're trying to do so it's it's perfect
i'm excited to jump into it too um and
wizzalis red red kalis
uh yeah man thank you for the super chat
very cool
so you have a burning question you said
you want to make a feature film yes i do
do you want to be an executive producer
do you want to executive produce a
feature film
or be a major player in someone else's
um i mean
no i i want to direct man directing
that's the way to go
i want to help with the story i want to
direct
um editing you know i
i'm fine not editing i'm i'm i have a
music guy casey edwards
he is the man when it comes to music um
but as far as producing i think
naturally i will produce because i have
a lot of contacts and i have a lot of
resources that i want to get together
to make the movie happen that's what
producing is
um you know if you are planning
a birthday party you're producing a
birthday party you're getting you're
calling everyone hey can you make it
hey do you get presents and all this
like you're producing a birthday party
versus you know producing a movie so
it's a lot it's a lot bigger a lot more
work but that's generally
what it is um so i want to direct
um help with story
nate davis is writing it he's the writer
um so he's definitely gonna knock that
out
but no i i don't really have any
interest in making other people's movies
i'll make my own
that's i mean that's that's where it's
at you know so
yeah all right getting into it getting
back into it
where were we we were getting these
little blocks here holding control
let's make a cube we'll move it up and
let's go ahead and
just make it editable and we'll drop
the y-axis or drop the gizmo down on the
y-axis
we'll scale it down
um let's see these these water tanks are
just a little bit wider than the seat
so i'm just gonna move these guys down
and they're sitting
basically like right down there
that's perfect okay cool
so from here let's go ahead and use
just our faces and we'll pull these
faces up and out
and the watering cans looks like they
come up above the gas tank by a
a minute here so boom that's good
and i think they're a little thicker
personally
something like that
amazing amazing
all right and we'll rotate this guy
back because there's a little bit of a
lean to it so
remember we talked about world and local
orientation
let's hide the camera and take a look at
this so if i were to move this back
the world or no if i would hit w and you
see the gizmo it's changing
look this is local if i hold ctrl to
duplicate
all right you see how it goes down into
the seat you know
i don't want that i want world
orientation
so that they're stacked like books on a
shelf
you know what i mean i think y'all know
what i mean
all right
so those are our that's that those are
our water tanks because
i'm guessing this dude's motorcycle
overheats 24
7. all right so that's why he has those
things let's um
let's get this this little like uh
cargo case on the back so i'm just gonna
make a cube
normally i want it to be oriented
properly
and let's go ahead and like crunch this
down
based off the watering cans it's a
little bit wider than the watering cans
but not as tall
and it is probably longer than it is
tall so it's probably looking
something like that and it's sitting
right on the
on the seat here
right about there
awesome and that'll be a fun thing to
dive into i think
depending on how long it takes us to to
block this out
maybe i'll i'll give a quick pull and
we'll say hey which which
model which piece of the bike do we want
to take
further into detail um
but we'll we'll get there we'll get
there certainly
oh you see how it's off
yeah you see how it's off right here so
if you if you
try and eyeball it yeah you can get you
can get close but it's not going to be
exact so you just type in the coordinate
down there
bam
this is looking fun um
gabriel no i am not finishing this whole
thing today
my knees would break i'm standing like
i'm standing up
i can't do i can't stand up for 20 hours
this is not a 24-hour charity live
stream
nah man this this will probably go um
for a little bit but
but now i can't finish this whole thing
i'm finishing the block out i'm
finishing an
extensive block out of this so i can
continue to work on this
so i'm showing you guys my process when
it comes to
building really detailed models and
that's with the block out you got to
start with the block out
that's the way to go and on corridor
digital.com we're gonna be coming out
with um with a a what is it it's called
functional filmmaking you guys have
probably
seen trailers for it but i teach a class
we recorded this like months ago
but i teach a class on how to model
texture light all this
a film camera and the first thing i
start out with is the block out you guys
will see
you know you'll see if you guys if you
know you know
all right that probably made half sense
to everybody i speak in like
half phrases
all right let's get some kombucha going
jay what shortcuts do i use in c4d man i
like to call them out as i use them
um w is a good one switch between world
and local
orientation um
ul loop selection uk or no kl
kl is a loop cut comb
appreciate the super chat man cheers to
you
uh you said that i've seen yourself and
wren wear those sweet c4d shirts before
where'd you get them
loving those streams the c4d shirts we
got from grayscale gorilla
actually grayscale gorilla.com
and dude they taught me so much they i
oh man they taught me a whole bunch so
remember when i tried to
model that lamborghini on the stream and
failed yeah i went to grayscale gorilla
and i watched
their topology crap crash topology crab
course no topology crash course
and it blew my mind i learned so much
and that's how i was able to model those
four items that i modeled
um last week on that breakdown for you
guys
simon you put on some music dude
i leave it this way so you guys can put
on your own music
play your own stuff in the background
you know
um i think my music would be
cool for some people maybe a little
repetitive after three or four hours
for most so that's why i leave it i
leave it open so you guys can
play your own tunes you know gotta mix
it you know just mix it in the
background a little bit
okay okay okay thomas what up son thank
you for the super chat your enthusiasm
for 3d art creation is infectious i love
it dude that's what's
up man let's keep making stuff so i
don't know all the answers
it's why we're learning and growing
together
all right um i try and teach what i know
and then i ask you guys for the rest so
that's how it works here
all right um
[Music]
let's see let's see let's get these like
little saddle bag
pieces okay let's try and get those
going do we want to do anything else
with this let's uh okay let's give it a
fillet
let's throw it in the oven um
zero no no no no one subdivision
and we just kind of like bring it down
like that you see how that kind of
matches that box a little bit just a
little bit
it's close right and it's not editable
so we can still work those numbers
we can work that that fill it you know
now the gas cans we can probably
we can probably block these oh man this
be a really fun thing to model is this
gas can maybe maybe that's what we do
once we block out the bike we work on
the gas can or not the gas can the
watering cans
oh my god oh pardon me this is freaking
uh
these gt's cayenne aid man this thing is
spicy
daniel y'all with the super chats much
appreciated thank you thank you
passion for the art is awesome you got
me back in a blender
are you a dual monitor man or an ultra
wide guy
i'm a dual monitor man i got two i got
the stream on this side and i got c4d on
this side
honestly i want to get three going um
because
honestly it'd be nice to have the stream
on one side or like maybe the stream is
up here or something i don't know
i just need more monitors
y'all are awesome let's take uh
let's just take like five minutes here
i'm gonna answer some questions
hit me up with the at thing do the at
punisher so i can see
all right otherwise it's just white and
gray on my screen it's craziness
so just give me give me a little at
punisher right here and i'll answer
whatever questions y'all have
and i appreciate you guys joining me
good times
um all right
it's flying let's start from the top all
right let's start from the top
uh what music am i into i love ambient
music um
i love ambient music i'm also a drummer
so i love me some like trip hops some
drum and bass um
i love prog rock porcupine tree is
probably my favorite i love mute math
is a good band as far as ambient music
goes
i mean brian eno is like the godfather
of ambient music
i mean it goes from there um stars of
the lid is a good one
very like classical and uh
dramatic you know and then you got guys
like
mount shrine mount shrine is like one of
my all-time favorites
recently super good um all right what
else
are those bone phones worth it yes
moving on am i using a staining desk
yes moving on um how do you
how do you fill it after connect to
object
so like once you make it editable you
just bevel it you hit it with that bevel
dang there's so many questions oh my god
um speed round definitely interested in
functional filmmaking you're doing a
modeling one and i know that
nick is doing one for story what are
some of the other ones um ren's doing
one on how to like
make a video for an idea sam's doing one
on editing nico's doing one on cameras
um oscar hey clint love the work
personality keep up the good work
thank you sir the discord link is broken
uh oh that's not good
well i'll have to fix that soon
after this video after the stream uh you
might be able to go to my last week's
video and
and click that one octane redshift i'm
an octane
um best place to start learning c4d
right here son
you're in the right place otherwise i
love gray scale gorilla
i learned all my stuff there um david
ariev is a good one too
and ej from idesign what age did i start
doing cg
i started doing cg god
two thousand
nine maybe 2009
hmm will you do more than block out on
this stream um
yeah i'm going to finish the block out
i'll probably go into detail on one of
the pieces and i'm going to do an art
review
you've been drinking my chai lattes for
a while heck yeah that's amazing
um
let's see
do you think you can do any tutorials
that only use after effects i don't have
c4d but love to do 3d vfx
yes they're coming they're coming that's
guys that's why
that's a big reason why i i stepped away
from corridors because i have so many
ideas and so many things i want to do
and i just did not have time to do it
all so i had to choose it was a tough
choice
but i believe it was the right choice so
got a lot of ideas for this channel
and i got a lot of things that i want to
show you guys so stay tuned for that if
you're not subscribed
y'all hit that subscribe button and hit
the bell notification thingy
you know how youtube works all right you
know how it works
what else render warrior welcome
you're not late better late than never
though
but then i just admit you're late you're
not late it's like an hour dude you're
good
um
what else what kind of computer am i
rocking man this is a i built this thing
with the help of some of my friends ah
man i got a rtx quadro 6k
up in here i got like 64 gigs of ram
uh you know the motherboard is in there
somewhere
1000 watt power supply you know how your
computer stuff you know
so many questions
um am i going to eyeball the
measurements the whole time yes yes i am
i'm going to eyeball these measurements
i'm not trying to get it exact but we go
we got
we got a thousand viewers live viewers
once again y'all
heck yeah thank you guys so much shout
outs
amazing absolutely amazing how good is
that quadro for gaming you use it for
that man honestly i use the quadro for
uh
all my really intense scenes and
i hadn't had an issue with vram since
then man 24 gigs of vram is like
killer so good let's get back to it
y'all
it's about time long john is correct
let's get back to it all right all right
colonel been a long time huh
all right um i'm gonna stop rambling now
okay
let's let's do these saddle bags
all right let's uh
just beat box the whole time um
saddlebags all right we're going back in
let's keep building this thing
thank you for the questions y'all i'll
answer more
later as we go as we do our thing
all righty so this
is okay just eyeballing it it comes up
to about halfway
up the seat in terms of our x-axis it
comes
up about this far and then for the back
we got probably something like that
and this thing doesn't start
until about here
and it comes out probably i'll make that
editable
and i'll start messing with the polygons
now comes out maybe about
there cool and it's going to be
symmetrical all right so remember the
video last week don't
model more stuff than you have to
all right so let's get that axis right
on the zero
zero point oh hold on hold on
we gotta be in model mode try that again
get that axis right on the zero
boom and then we hold alt
to make this cube that we have selected
an automatic child of this symmetry and
then you got to just change the symmetry
settings
so it works and now we got some symmetry
on this mug
boom and you only have to work on the
one guy
hit on the one dude
right and you do half the work
tweak thank you for the super chat you
gotta say that between robot tutorial
and these streams you have really
inspired me to start actually doing some
personal works
yes dude yes that's amazing hopefully
we can all have jobs doing awesome
creative work
or yeah just our passions that's that's
the life having the job doing the
passion
so you know if you guys can make that
happen it's a long
it's a long journey it's certainly a
long journey um but it's certainly
possible
and it won't happen if you guys don't
put time into the stuff you love doing
so treat that stuff with care it's very
important you got to do what you love
okay saddle bags boom
we got to cut it here because this thing
kind of does a funny little taper
uh boom like this
and then we kind of get let's go ahead
and
grab this piece and i want to move the
gizmo all the way to plus
z it'll execute
oh it's not working huh how about we
just force it i'm gonna hit l and just
move it
manually man i didn't even need to do
that
see there's a million ways to do things
just grab the edge
bring it in right up to that point there
kl we'll get that loop cut again
bam and it kind of does like a
like a ramp like that like a little ramp
boom awesome now we need to get these
well technically we just scale it so
grab the whole thing
and no no i'm lying i'm lying
we need to grab all these points
without grabbing that point
holding shift to grab everything here
and we want let's see
it's the best way to do this kl we want
to go right down the middle
and let's just bring these points in t
for scale
i'll bring these points in t for scale
well they all kind of come down at about
the same
the same level all right so i was i was
on to something here so holding shift
to grab all these solo mode
and we'll get these guys down here too
holding shift
bam to get all your stuff hit t for
scale
we scale that down
awesome awesome awesome
dude um be merrick to
congratulations on getting that uh bfx
internship yeah man
just learn as much as you can learn as
much as you can be a sponge
absorb it all it will pay off
it will pay off indeed i promise
like that's pretty i mean that's pretty
close for this block out here of this
little saddle piece maybe i bring in
maybe it's coming out a little far
let me just kind of bring that in a
little bit
and we can bring these guys these points
up right here we can just kind of
scrunch them down
scale them down and move them up a
little bit
like that
hey there we go
boom and maybe we can
grab one of these points here scoot this
thing
back a little bit just to give it a
little roundness to it
and technically i think these points
here
scale as well so
these guys need to come down let's go
ahead and solo again so we can see what
we're doing
grab that guy and i think that'll be
it just these guys here and here
and here and we'll scale them
something like that
awesome
very nice let's save a new iteration
sweet you guys hanging in there doing
okay
thumbs ups let's see those thumbs ups
y'all
you're having a good one
freddy i'm glad that my voice is calming
and relaxing
because man it's so stressful trying to
get this stream up there's so much to do
before beforehand so that's cool
all right any time management tips here
while working yeah don't get distracted
don't pick up your phone don't use your
phone uh i like to set a timer i think
the most practical piece of advice here
is to set a timer
i'll set a one hour timer and i'll work
straight for an hour and i set a
10-minute timer and i take a 10-minute
break
doing something that you know doesn't
require my brain
focusing on something i'll go for a walk
it's probably about the best thing you
can do
so set the timers and try and work
through them if you can't focus for a
full hour
focus for 10 minutes 20 minutes 30
minutes however long
i have i learned that i have
adhd as well as a
a mild version of ocd i think we all got
some stuff
all right and for me i'm i'm actually
able to
despite the adhd i can really focus on
something for a long time
um obviously it's still different when i
have the stream going
um because i got to go back and forth
and i'm talking everything out the whole
time i'm looking at the stream looking
at the chat
going back and forth so it's it's tough
to
work as efficiently as i would if i were
just quiet and working
you know um so this is a little slower
because you know you got to keep it
entertaining you know
um but yeah set that timer
that's the best piece of advice okay
let's see
if we can't get
this piece here control it
up
like this
and control it in like that
and they kind of connect
a little bit and then we can take these
inside pieces
hit d for extrude and kind of just get
some thickness on that
and but you want to create those caps
you want to create caps
boom just like that
hey there we go we're back
marcelino thank you for the super chat
much appreciate it man thank you thank
you he says bro i love you
not in a gay way like i i hope you the
best
um and i forget about cinema blender is
the way
sun it doesn't matter what 3d program
you're using
dude it's just a matter of how what you
can do in that 3d program
that's all it comes down to oh man that
your your super chat reminded me of uh
the the super kobe fan
video have you guys ever seen that oh my
god it's so funny just type in
um crazy kobe fan uh
interview and it's this dude who like
pops up and he's got an orchid for kobe
he's like he's like kobe like man we can
take a day trip down to santa barbara
um he's like i'll get you an orchid baby
like dude it's so funny it's one of my
favorite videos
that dude's hilarious um all right
let's see let's um let's grab all these
points
and scoot them back a little bit so that
this plastic piece is just right up
against the
seat there that feels good to me
cool yeah that feels good
oh there's a little piece here on the
front wheel
let's let's get distracted a little bit
let's go in here on the front wheel
let's grab let's see
looks like the top piece down to
the middle right there we're gonna hit
up we're gonna break it up
and we'll scale it up something like
that no maybe we just move it
like that then we hit d extrude it just
a little bit
something like that yeah that's gonna be
our fender
keep the mud off the tire
and let's do the boring thing y'all we
need to name our stuff let's take this
moment to just organize our scene and
and rename some things here
that's my fender this is a water
can
got our back seat our front seat
gas tank yep water can two
we'll group those
um this is our cargo i'm just make it
editable
um let's see the cargo
container
awesome um and then this symmetry what
would you even call this i don't think
it's storage i think it's just like
uh back fender or something
and what i like to do is actually take
all of this
um front vendor i'll take all of this
ctrl g and i'll just type call this geo
for geometry
so everything is really clean save your
stuff
save your stuff you don't want this to
crash
last night when i was making this block
out for the thumbnail
i finished it and it crashed on me so i
had to do it again this morning
so make sure y'all save let's save a new
iteration
and it's fun i like the iterations
because not only are they
like really handy when trying to go back
to previous projects
or previous versions of your creation
because you can pull stuff from that um
but it's cool to see
the the progress the timeline like how
it all came together so
that's very very fun for me
so already this is a lot more detailed
than the blockout i did for the
thumbnail so i'm digging this
um let's just you know
because i get distracted and because i
do things that aren't necessary let's go
into this tire
kl that's your loop cut let's make two
of them so one down the middle holding
shift i'll add one
ul is loop selection and t for scale
and i'll just get those guys out like
that and
let's go ahead and loop select these
outer pieces here
and we'll scale them in but not
on the on the x you see how you scale it
there and it like kind of scoots in
towards the x axis
we don't want that so uncheck i'm sorry
z uncheck the z
that way
they kind of move without scaling in so
i just want to
give it a little bit of roundness there
and we'll do the same for the front
wheel
kl holding shift to get the middle slice
we're going to add the one we're going
to add one by hitting a little add
ul is loop selection holding shift to
get both of those
t for scale we'll scale them out
and ul once again to get those outer
pieces
making sure that the z is unchecked and
we just kind of
scale those in oh why is that
why is it going crazy on me
kill them in just a little bit
awesome okay so we got you know the
handlebars the dashboard and the engine
like the engine block and all that stuff
that makes up that the radiator and
everything
um all right
so let's try for the dashboard
let's try and get the dashboard going
see what we can do here so i'm just
gonna make a cube
hit t automatically make this thing
editable
go to object mode and let's scale this
thing down
bring it up here kind of rotate it a
little bit
rotate it forward and it looks like
it is kind of in the gas tank it's like
sitting right up in here
and it's cut out so let's see go to edge
mode
kl we'll make a center cut
we'll uh we'll hit the add
button and then we'll just kind of scale
this up
we'll make another cut right about there
and we can go ahead and dissolve
these faces n well all three i guess
right
let's solo it so it's easier to see m
n oh totally didn't work i'm just gonna
delete it
boom and we need to bridge these so m b
in edge mode
m b and we'll bridge
those pieces so now it's now we're good
to go here
um we can go back
out
all right let's see so it almost looks
like this gas tank
kind of well it's both the gas tank
fills out
this area but this dashboard kind of
tapers
a little bit the inside at least the
inside will taper
so maybe we go ahead and do a loop
selection on this piece
um or grab ctrl
a to select all the points uo to
optimize just in case we have
overlapping points
and we'll bring all these down
um
kl for that loop cut once again
boom boom and i want to
take these points and just kind of bring
them in towards each
other a little bit like that
and we'll do the same for all four of
them so there's a little bit of taper on
the inside
like that
and the gas tank let's give this gas
tank a cut down the center
kl right down the center like that
[Music]
um
and let's go ahead and open this gas
tank up so i'm going to select
basically all of these points all these
edges here
and try and open it up to fill out the
space t for scale
it's pretty darn close we can
take let's see
let's grab these polygons here loop
selection
holding shift to grab the front ones and
we'll bring it forward
and that feels a little a little closer
to how this thing actually is
um it feels a little stretched to me as
well
so
let me just look at this bike here and
see
hmm did the front seat
from here it looks like the handlebars
actually
come out of this hole right here
based on the reference image
that's pretty crazy
so it looks like the yeah these front
wheels
are connected i'm just kind of talking
out loud here
um holding ctrl i'm gonna make a
cylinder
and i'm just gonna give it like i don't
know
it doesn't need that many polygons so
i'll give it like eight or something
and it doesn't need any height ones
either and let's go ahead and just like
skinny it up pull it out here
and it looks to me
like this thing comes up
and goes to kind of the outside
underneath section let's go ahead and
make it yeah it is editable let's make
it editable
and let's move the gizmo using that axis
center tool
down to negative y so we can rotate it
this way
really take a look at this thing here it
kind of comes up to
this dash piece and i think the
dashboard actually like comes out a
little bit
like it almost does
almost does one of these things
like mud flaps almost your knees go
underneath that
cool and let's while we're here on this
uh
on this dashboard let's go ahead and
round out the top so
to me that is basically just
taking these edges here and bringing
them
in
and it's a little tall so we can bring
that down
and it kind of has like a little lip on
the front too
so we can grab those hit d
and push it out just a little bit and
it tapers so we'll grab these far edges
here
and bring them back like that
cool psy what's up dude thank you for
the super chat
uh he says hey clint i hope you and the
members of the stream are having a great
day
excited for the stream good to see you
push limits with every stream man
thank you so much that is awesome yeah i
got a
really try and do my thing here and uh
and push myself because i think that's
the way to get better you gotta
you gotta get out of your comfort zone
and and
really try and push yourself so i'm glad
you see that man i appreciate it thank
you so much
tom the super chat appreciated man
why no mirror it's
it's not i don't know i could
and i might when i get into like the
really rather i will when i get into the
insane details of this thing
but honestly like i'm cool right now
with the way this is it's not really any
extra work to do what i just did
um i'm certainly gonna get a mirror here
on this little like
the shocks piece the suspension
we'll definitely have that
all right so let's see let's take a look
at this and see how this is gonna look
so the suspension based off of
reference kind of comes
up underneath and into
like the radiator area underneath the
dashboard
you know i feel like it'd be a lot
easier to
then do a photo scan of this but
again you gotta gotta challenge yourself
so that's what i'm doing here
getting that challenge
okay
so this piece this cylinder
kind of tapers
up and out so i'm going to grab
these cuts here and you see
if i were to do it with world
orientation how it looks weird
actually in that case
it actually looks fine either one you do
so that's good
um we need to make another cut
scale that up kind of
kind of does one of those why is that
scaling all weird
oh it's because this thing ah i messed
that up all right let's try that
again there we go
awesome something like that
this piece could have let's see
a tube on it and it'll be plus
z let's scale it down and i'm just
trying to get like a little
break caliper piece in here
the height comes down we don't need any
of those segments
yeah something like that
and we can take this let's see we'll
take this tube
and we'll just control drag it
the other side and we'll take both of
those tubes
and let's control drag them into this
back wheel
and i'll just move them back here
yeah something like that
perfect perfect all right and this shock
piece let's go ahead and give it some
symmetry
and we're getting close we're getting
close to our block out
um
all right so i'm hit l make sure this
gizmo is zeroed out and i'll hold alt
and throw it into that symmetry modifier
wonderful
so we just need to kind of finish the
front piece with the handlebars
and then the engine piece and then we
can take
i'll probably take this watering the
water can here
and model that to completion and then
we'll get into the weekly challenge
results
but this is going to set me up here for
a full detail of this bike
which is going to be intense but it's
going to be awesome
okay so the handlebars
hmm
[Music]
let's go ahead and zoom into this
picture here
and jenkin out on me again
so give me a second
all right so ah come on
so annoying
what the heck what the heck
uh something with this tablet man
gotta get that update all right
we're doing good y'all we have
consistently at like 900 people
amazing absolutely amazing um
you know if you guys are just joining me
we're modeling a motorcycle we're
blocking it out
the important step that cannot be missed
when doing stuff that is so detailed is
to block it out go easy on yourself get
the brushstrokes
sketch it out do your thing super easy
um
not really but it's just long and
tedious it's a long and tedious process
um and uh to all you guys with the super
chats i appreciate you all
so much thank you guys so much and if
you guys
want to help out one extra little step
here click the link
in the description the skillshare link
in the description click that all right
that's going to help me out um it'll
show that you know
i'm doing good with the skillshare guys
and it'll also help you out with two
free weeks of skillshare so
it's a win-win you know it is a win-win
indeed
okay let's get this thing going
bam slide these guys down
something like that yeah
so the handlebars it looks like the
handlebars
you know they kind of what's the best
way to do this
the easiest way to do this um
maybe just with a cube to be honest so
let's take our tank here hold control
make a cube
scale it down and position it kind of
right
right up in here let's scale that down
and this will be like the base of our
of our handlebars here um bartek thank
you thank you for the super chat
i really appreciate it thank you for
joining i hope you're learning something
um you know it's tough to try to
entertain and educate
and do this at the same time
it's a lot it's a lot and i hope it's
working i appreciate you guys
hanging out with me and sticking in
okay so the handlebars trying to orient
these things
properly let's get them
coming out like this and
they kind of come up in here
uh nina thank you for the super chat
is it even a c4d stream if it doesn't
glitch out at least once thanks for
sharing the process
watching this at midnight here loving
the low five vibe
that's awesome man that's very very cool
thanks for sticking with me all the way
through midnight that's a lot i know
but it means a lot man
yeah i mean it's a live stream what do
you expect there's going to be some
glitchiness
let's go ahead and uh mw and extrude
enter
hit d to pull this out
we're going to do kl holding shift
to get these little pieces on the end
here
d will bring them up
and kl again
to let's see how do we want to do this
they're kind of like they're kind of
angled so
i know technically this isn't right but
if i just
kind of angle these guys in this will at
least give me
the idea of where i'm where i'm going
with these things and then i'm gonna hit
d to push these things out
that's so janky but that's i mean that's
it
we're blocking it out trying to get the
feel there like really
to go in here and do this full detailed
would take
probably two hours to do those
handlebars it's gonna be a long
process i'm getting overwhelmed looking
at this but you gotta take it
in baby steps one piece at a time
all right maybe we don't do it the janky
way
let's try and do this proper um
let's move these down again that's local
versus world orientation if i try to
move it down
with world orientation nah w
will get you that local orientation it's
what you want
and
yeah hit d
or even mw extrude enter
and then d we'll bring it out pete mctee
yo thanks for the super chat appreciate
you he says clint you're my hero i love
cordon i just started vr modeling
so dope to randomly see your channel and
see this dude that's what's up man
thanks for stopping by thanks for
hanging out
vr modeling yeah it's uh it's pretty
sweet my buddy
don don allen iii he um
he's really into vr modeling he's like
the vr xr master
and he turned me on to it i think it's
it might be the way i
build out a giant colossus fossil
um like skeleton structure i might give
that a shot
do it that way and tom i see you thank
you thank you
two hour handlebars with mirror is one
hour dude
you're so right you're so right oh my
goodness
that's amazing two hours a two hour
handlebar model is a one hour model
absolutely with symmetry with symmetry
all right let's see um
[Music]
see if i can't get these guys and
this is definitely a symmetry situation
i know
but i'm just doing this the quick way
which
again should be with symmetry right
all right move these guys back
oh come on yeah screw it dude you know
what screw it
symmetry kl slice it down the middle
get all these points that you don't care
about
and just delete them delete
i don't know why i didn't get that piece
uh i didn't get that piece let's try
that
jankiness jankiness
boom make that cut let's just
let's do this right
get rid of this point there's a random
point m n
no m n
there we go i think that what is going
on here
now we got now we got problems
what's going on delete that
let's dissolve this line here
no one wants it no one cares about it
uh this one
mn get out of there
and then we're going to go ahead and m b
it's going to be a bridge tool m b
bam bridge it up close it up and then
for safe measure
go to polygon or uh point mode control a
you can see point selected
50 hit uo optimize if that number goes
down that means you had duplicated
points on top of each other
you don't want that let's delete
what we were trying to do before and
let's throw it into symmetry select it
hold alt to make the symmetry modifier
an automatic parent
of what we're doing here let's get out
of
solo mode and let's go ahead and like i
don't know
start pulling these points back let's do
what we were actually trying to do
pull these points back let's rotate
this a little bit something like
something like that
that feels much better much better
awesome ethan thank you for the five
dollar super chat
appreciated tom man i see you i see the
hearts man thank you guys so much
heck yeah
[Music]
doing good stuff ronin visual thanks for
modding
thanks for uh helping out in the chat
much appreciated you guys are taking
care of the stuff i can't see
can't do it without you all all right
okay so let's try and get finish out the
front piece
of this
all right
so janky all right one sec here we go
we back we're back
so we have like a
more watering cans and headlights
um so let's see what we can do let's
make that cube we'll make it editable
and we'll start scaling it down to fit
how we want
daddy wayne my goodness thank you for
that super chat son
doing big things i appreciate you
i appreciate you very much
all right we'll scale this thing down
it's about probably about that size
right
and it's angled a little bit so we want
to get that nice little angle on it
walk it back just a touch
maybe something like
something like that
you know i i almost feel like these
handlebars and the dashboard
are a little too far forward so i'm
going to move these back
and let's rotate the handlebars up so
they match the axis or they match the
like rotation of the wheel because
technically when you rotate these
handlebars it's going to move
these guys here which moves the wheel so
we want to get that nice and and lined
up
all right that guy's about there and
then we have if we control drag this
and we make these like turn signals
these guys are angled down for whatever
reason
and push back just a little bit
and i'm not going to worry too much
about symmetry i'll just control drag it
over there
that's pretty good
so another thing the blockout does is
helps me see like
are my proportions correct do i have
things lined up and do they
spell out the shape of the object
if they don't it's easier to adjust
fewer things than it is to just adjust a
bunch of things
um so that's another benefit of the
blockout
gabriel thank you so much for the super
chat
you guys are too kind thank you thank
you and komlesh
says what's up how do you feel about
modeling in maya
dude i used uh maya for three months
when i was trying to figure out what
program i wanted to get into
i liked it but i ended up on uh in c4d
i used 3ds max for six years though as
well
um but i honestly i don't remember
modeling in maya
um i remember i made a shark that's
that's about all i remember uh it was
fun
modeling in any program is fun man
yeah but the end of the day it doesn't
really matter what you use it's just
what you make
with it okay
so now it looks like we have
some sort of like oil thing an
oil tank a water can
thing on the front let's go ahead and
make that this guy's bike is so cool i
love it
and that's kind of pushed back
to about there and strapped
to the frame that holds his mirrors and
stuff so we'll get that too
but let's go in and detail
out this little piece here kl that's
going to be your loop cuts
and let's get that boom we'll select
these guys here
and scale them out a little bit
extrude this up
and like same for them for these pieces
something like that
do we technically need this cut here i
don't know
sweet all right and
let's get the frame of this thing down
this will be symmetry
i know this will be symmetry so let's
use this object
to spawn our cylinder holding control
we'll scale it down and we'll move it
out to the side
um let's go ahead and change it to eight
sides we don't need any height segments
we'll scale it down we're pretty small
here
we'll scale it up
and we'll get it basically like right in
there
and we'll make it editable
and grab those points bring them up
there
virtually there thank you for the super
chat have you ever used blender and what
are your thoughts
i've used blender like barely um and i
think but i think it's awesome
yeah i think it's great
there's a lot of a lot of fighting on
whether blender is better or c4d is
better
honestly i think it's a it's an argument
that is pointless
because hey guys what's better my left
hand or my right hand oh
they're the same thing you were just
born using one of them
so you're used to one it's like have you
ever switched thought of switching your
left hand like
no because i use my right hand and i'm
fine at it i don't need to switch to my
left hand
that's the way i think of it um use what
you enjoy
that's that's really it at the end of
the day it's cool that blender is free
though
you can you know you need some cool
stuff and you can get into
3d with blender because it's free
and a lot of people stick with it
because that's what they got into it
with you know
jacob uh the super chat once again
you guys killing it today my goodness he
says thank you for the good vibes and
the great content my girlfriend
is so tired of listening to me talk
about service imperfections
dude that's great oh man
yeah yeah i'll zone out i'll start
looking at the wall
um specifically at the surface
imperfections i'll i'll be like dang
that looks good
so i know how you feel man it's really
funny
let's give this thing symmetry all right
let's get this
lined up at the zero hold alt throw it
in the symmetry modifier
put it on the right plane and then we
can start duplicating these things
um so let's
uh let's grab this and move that to the
top
rotate hold control
and get this kind of lined up
now i feel like
this guy needs to be rotated back
a little bit more let's take that down
to negative
y and rotate this thing back like this
yeah this one let's go ahead and
move it down here
and it kind of it looks like it comes
out too
this piece comes out like that it opens
up
this piece can angle back a little bit
just get right up in there scale it up a
little bit
awesome and this piece let's bring it
out
and rotate it
down so it's coming straight down and
maybe we angle it
out just a little bit too cool
and let's bring that point the axis down
to
the bottom and we'll control
rotate so it brings it down to that last
little
piece here that's like our frame
and we want to make sure that that stuff
is in the symmetry modifier
i don't know why why is that not working
because it won't let me add new stuff
maybe i have to
throw it back in the symmetry modifier
or maybe
i have to put it into a null object
there we go i put into a null object and
then it works
ferret yo man he says huge props for
your pursuing your dream man love the
content so far keep it up thank you sir
thank you guys for joining me thanks for
sticking with me if you're new to my
channel
welcome it's good to have you guys if
you're back um
and you're watching the streams like
it's like you normally do thank you for
sticking with me for so long you guys
are awesome
thank you so much
all right let's throw down some
let's see let's get this gizmo up to the
top hold ctrl
make a cube scale it down and these are
our
our mirrors i'm gonna
make some big ones here this goes up top
and we'll control drag
or the smaller mirrors and it kind of is
a little bit forward and
tilt it up a little bit push that back
and we can even rotate it just a little
bit
as well
this dude's bike is crazy like the more
i look at this bike i'm just like
oh my god it's so cool
okay so i think at this point we just
need to build the frame
the you know like the housing at the
bottom and
for that i'm gonna start with the cube
so let's scale it down make it editable
with c
and we'll scrunch it up
so it's basically as thick as the gas
tank maybe a little skinnier
and it's certainly up in there
and let's go ahead and just get it to
the skinniest point of the gas tank
there
and we'll get this off the ground i
think i think that's
probably good there
let's grab this point and bring this guy
back
because that's going to be our radiator
it goes up
into the motorcycle
and let's make a cut boom like somewhere
right up in here
ctrl drag it out
yeah something something like that maybe
and the radiator is going to sit on here
so i'm going to hit up and break that up
i'll move it out just a little bit and
we'll hit d
no hold ctrl to scale it
and let's make it a little bit wider
so i want that gizmo right up in there
and we're going to go ahead and we want
to center it
and we'll open it up just a little bit
that's our radiator piece and
it's it's hollow so we need to hit
md to patch that that's the uh
what is it create um patch polygon hole
or something
what's the name of that tool close
polygon hole
yeah md all your shortcuts are on the
right you gotta learn them y'all
okay
let's extend this guy well let's name
let's name it radiator
and this we'll just call like and we'll
just call the hull
i guess and
let's rename some of this stuff up here
this is uh
i guess this is a water tank too i or i
guess maybe oil
oil tank
this is a frame piece um this is
our rear view mirror
another frame piece and another frame
piece
we got to stay organized y'all there's
me a lot of pieces here
um side view mirror
and the symmetry will be our mirrors
turn signal right turn signal
and left turn signal
headlight and let's see
dashboard
awesome artem thank you
sir for the super chat i appreciate you
man
so you say hey i am a long time fan of
corridor and freddie w early days and
just found you
i missed this week's challenge by one
day but i'll participate
next week that is the spirit man that's
what's up
yeah the challenges are great you know i
i keep talking about how it's a really
cool way
for people to dive into their passion
and learn something new
or keep working on something they love
every week you have to do it
consistently that's the biggest thing
you have to do consistently and keep
working it like a muscle
um so i look forward to you
participating in this week's weekly
challenge which will be announced
at the end of the art review after this
lesson
and soundwave i see you too man thank
you for that super chat
he says love your work keep up the great
work brother thank you
you too you too you keep it up oh man
we're almost ah we're almost there you
know just got a little
couple more pieces to go and we're going
to get into the weekly challenge
winners and all the honorable mentions i
can't go over all of them there's 325
submissions
it was a whopper of a contest um
i'm giving you guys my surface
imperfection pack as well as all four
of those models in last week's video for
you guys to mess around and play with
um so it's gonna be cool it's gonna be
very cool i'll probably spend another
i don't know 20 20 minutes or so on this
thing maybe
i'll work in the water tank here and
then we'll get to the art review
so let's get to it alrighty alright
sweet this is looking cool even as a low
poly like
it it looks awesome like this is
definitely
uh if you guys ever played katamari it's
definitely like something that would be
in katamari
i love it
okay
so let's bring this
back to this point here
and i'll probably just grab this piece
here and kind of move it back in to this
point
and kl we can just grab
we solo it we can grab this polygon or
this edge here
something like that
and i'm not going to worry too much
about you know the bike
i feel like i feel like uh i want to
shorten this bike
just a little bit it feels a little long
to me so
so here's what i'm going to do
i need to crunch the hole back a little
bit
the gas tank so i'm hit zero grab those
points
and move them this way let's grab the
seat
let's move it up the same distance
to about there and i'm gonna grab all
this stuff in the back
as one piece so let me let me solo this
again
and i'll grab these polygons
i'll move them up a little bit
and then i'm gonna hit zero wait what
what did that do undo
uh redo control y redo there we go
i'm gonna hit zero and let's just try
and grab
all of this stuff we got to be in model
mode for that
grab all these and move them up
something like that tala have thank you
thank you sir 100
yeah that feels better
that feels better to me just a little
little adjustments like that again we're
trying to
figure out the shape of our object
we want to really define the object
at you know with with shape that's what
we're doing
it doesn't feel like the object then you
know you got to figure out where to make
your tweaks and stuff
now there's a ton of stuff going on on
the engine
but that's the detail i'm not going to
worry about that right now
um it has a kickstand i don't think we
need to worry about the kickstand either
but this is basically at a point now
where we can go in
and start adding a butt ton of detail
to this um
now i guess it'd be fun to
give it some light let's give it some
light
bam uh let's get a sunlight going
the first attempt thank you thank you
thank you sir
much appreciated in all seriousness i
feel like these live streams and videos
are gonna help me a lot with my
pre-rendering journey yes man
yes that's what's up
so i'm using octane make my stuff look
really nice let's give this thing a
a floor here we'll scale it way up
hey that's another thing too is scale so
let's make a figure
oh our bike is huge no good
so here's what we'll do let's fix that
let's put everything into that
uh geometry null object
let's take our gizmo if we were to scale
it now it'd be like
hovering right but let's take our gizmo
and drop it to the ground and
include all children use all objects so
now we can drop it
to the ground and get this bike
reasonably sized
something like that probably feels good
to me
and let's go ahead and uh grayscale
gorilla
they have their new um grayscale gorilla
hub
for c4d and it's the best thing ever
i'll make a psych
and delete the floor
move our psych around
you know something like that and we can
actually use an hdri
as well so let's right click this give
it
uh hdri link link the texture
and we can choose from all these awesome
hdris
where are they what happened where's my
stuff
where is my stuff what's going on
um plus library all my stuff should be
here
maybe clear the search okay yeah i guess
i had something in the search
you know you just pull up any one of
these hdris and take the sun maybe we
turn the sun off
and just let the hdri do its thing
um let's see
so it's blown out you can select the
image and change it to linear
and that'll normalize it
and there's just a ton of hdris that we
can choose from to really like
make this thing look nice i like this
concrete shelter one
it feels pretty good to me
tissue hey man thank you for the super
chat he says that
you love the positivity with everything
thanks for the fun streams and
educational videos man i got you
i got you all you guys thank you so much
for joining
joining me on this journey
boom we can give the background a
texture if we want
um we'll give it like a diffuse i i like
this blue
almost teal
and we'll up the roughness
so we get a little reflection in there
feels good and then you can just throw
an octane light on it you know
hold and shift go 90 on that
boom get it up there um let's hop out of
camera view
really get that thing up there and maybe
we just shine it on the background
you know like maybe that's going to be a
cool look for us
and you can hop into the camera and
under option you can uncheck the check
camera option
and then hop out of the camera and be
able to adjust your stuff
and we gotta turn this down it's a
little intense
and of course you can go in here and uh
you know give it some
some depth of field which you're not
really going to see too much of because
you know it's uh it's just a blue
background
but let's do you know we can add a color
correction to
to our stuff make things look a little
nicer maybe give it some vignetting if
you want
maybe some bloom
you know and work that cut off so it's
just hitting like uh
just the brightest points
but this is our block out this is our
block out we can hit it maybe with a
i don't know maybe a 24 mil
and we can pose it a little bit so
here's a trick here's a trick for you
guys you can go into the
uh keep saying geography geometry
go in here and just go ahead and select
everything
in fact if you control click this little
plus
it'll open up everything you possibly
have so go in
hold shift select everything go to
coordinates drop down freeze
transformation
and freeze all this way
if we go in here and we start moving
stuff around
and like we start posing stuff and and
all this
minus the the psych you know we start
moving this stuff around and
doing our thing here oh man all my stuff
is all over the place well all you have
to do
is select those objects and just hit
reset psr and they're going to snap back
to place
because i want to be able to pose this
motorcycle and
posing it is not the ideal position
for the bike to be in when we're
modeling we want it to be standing up
straight we want it to be
you know hitting all of the correct
lines and everything
we don't to be off axis so
what i do here is basically i freeze it
here so once we pose the bike
you know in a cool way doing a wheelie
or whatever we can just say hey reset
psr and it'll go back to the way it it
was meant
to be um super chats we got some super
chats up in here
let's see we got we got dtaq
they say they're 20 and left the dream
job at apple to focus on myself
yes dude people thought i was insane but
now
i'm deep in my 3d grind respect for
trusting your gut
where can i find real feedback for my
work
that's dude so cool man congratulations
to you
um yeah keep it up keep going i know you
already believe in yourself so you're
doing your thing
where can you find real feedback for
your work um
that's a good question i mean the weekly
challenges when i when i do the weekly
challenges here
i you know i'll choose the five winners
and i'll
talk about why they're so good and then
i'll go into honorable mentions and kind
of lightly touch on it
i don't really get into here's all the
things you need to do
but i'm working on a way within the next
couple weeks here i'm working on a way
to have like basically uh
an exclusive show that will be just that
it's art review so you submit your art
and i take a look at it and i really
break it down and it's just like an hour
long thing where i go through like
however many pieces of art maybe it's 20
pieces maybe it's 10 pieces of art
but i really i take an hour and i go
through and i really break it down so
um you'll know you'll know if you're
subscribed to this channel you guys will
know about that when it comes out all
right so
so definitely stay tuned um but dtaq
yeah keep keep going man keep crunching
join the discord server
i heard the link doesn't work right now
if maybe one of the mods want to drop a
link that works
that'd be helpful um but
i need to fix that link after the live
stream maybe look at one of the last
week's videos
and look at the discord link there and
you can see it
but definitely join the discord server
and get in there people are very helpful
they will help you with your stuff so
let's pose the bike
um let's choose the access center tool
drop it down to zero
i want to lean it so the bike is
chilling
and i want to move the handlebars
so everything that has to do with the
handlebars i want to group
together okay so that would be
let's see the mirrors the
handlebar the headlight let's just go in
here and select all this stuff it'd be
the turn signal headlight and if it's if
it's difficult to see here with the
lighting going on guys
you can hit n c
and that will take away the lighting
just for the viewport
um it's the front wheel it's the like
you know these little caliper pieces
um it's the fender
and i think uh yeah it's definitely the
oil piece
and the symmetry
so that's the front of the motorcycle
i'm gonna hit
alt g and it's going to group everything
into one null object all right so i'll
just call that
front and we want to
line this up here
hit l i'll move this to the center point
of the handlebars
and i'll push it back
so it's right up basically on the corner
of the handlebars that's where it's
turning from
and then we'll rotate this tire
a little bit like that
and we'll stand the bike up
a touch
and we'll get in there let's get in
there i'm gonna take my camera
and uh let's set that to a
24 yeah it's good maybe even like a
a 20 to get in there low
let's tilt our camera a little bit
just like just to get some of that bike
in there
and we'll open up this psych
um we should be able to change the width
yeah and the height
boom and that's looking pretty cool
and just you know get your focus right
and you can even get a closer maybe like
a 15.
get a cool angle in there you know
something fun
anyway you guys get the point that's
good stuff uh we missed the super chat
didn't we
uh bartek yo you say i'm pretty okay
with modeling but sucks with composition
and lighting can you suggest good
resources to learn more or give any tips
yeah lighting and composition is huge
man that's a huge
move um so
in in a similar way so i i blocked out
this motorcycle right
but when i did my parallel dimensions
render if you go back
i think i have a playlist for it and
it's the first video in that parallel
dimensions playlist
it's the environmental master class
um so in that video i start with concept
art
and i do it in photoshop and that's
where i'm working my composition
and as i you know go along the process
i'm constantly
referencing that uh that concept art to
make sure it's looking
you know looking correct if you want a
book on concept
or on uh on what do you call it
uh what is it goddamn composition if you
want a book on composition i got one for
you hold on it's right over here
[Music]
it's called visual story
and i learned a lot from this book
basically it
teaches you how to describe objects with
their shape
using silhouette and lighting and color
to push and pull things into the
foreground into the background
how to draw the eye dude this book is
solid this is one of my favorite ones
um yeah lots of good stuff here
um talks about you know how how stuff
stands out
in frames and images and whatnot um
it breaks it down really simple it talks
about movement and everything
it's a really really good one here's an
example like
you know going uh black and white so the
image is broken down into like black and
white
and you can really see can you tell what
the image is just in the black and white
you know um so that's why filmmakers
like to shoot things in black and white
sometimes it's because they're really
able to focus on just the shape
and the composition um so check out the
visual story bruce block
it's a really good one i learned a lot
from this guy
um so
you know where we got the bike here we
got this bike so what do you guys want
to do from this point
we can hop right into the uh the weekly
challenge winners
or i can take the next 30 minutes to
work on
like detailing out this water can
um what do you guys want to do
what y'all want to do let's go with the
weekly challenge all right challenge
details details details
challenge weekly challenge details
weekend
some detailing maybe a little bit of
both about a little bit
of both i won't take too long
but let's see what we can do
um see what we can do here we want to
model
this guy here that's what we want
um there's also a handle on this thing
too
let's see quentin the super chat
appreciate it man i hope you will like
uh i hope you will keep doing the
amazing share of knowledge and positive
energy as long as you can
as long as c4d exists absolutely
yeah man i'll do what i can do obviously
can't do this until i die
but i would like to be able to share my
knowledge until i die
i don't know if it's gonna be exactly
this way but
you know we'll figure it out together
so to me like
these are the two angles for uh
for this thing so let's see if we can't
we can't get this um figured out here
boom all right
so the watering can let's go ahead and
save our stuff
and i'm gonna reset psr on this bike
let's go ahead and select all these
objects reset psr
oh snap maybe that happened
because we changed the gizmo
so in that case i will undo
and undo and undo that's good to know
that's good to know it references the
gizmo so i need to be able to
i need to be able to like group that
stuff before i get into uh
into freezing the transformation
all right so let's take this piece here
this is our watering can
um let's find it up in here
watering can yep yep
and let's go ahead and unfreeze all
bear with me y'all come bear with me
there we go okay yeah so we'll stand
this up straight
save our stuff and we'll solo it this is
what we're working with okay
so
we gotta make some cuts we gotta make
some cuts
let's see i'll spend about 20 minutes on
this then we'll get into the weekly
challenge
all right so i'm seeing some stuff like
this probably got one and two there
all right we can bring in i'm gonna
again i'm gonna model the low poly
version of this so that we can make the
high poly version
all right first attempt the super chat
appreciate it man make sure you group
that windscreen and mirror assembly
with the frame and not the handlebars
also looks great so far
thank you man thank you thank you good
advice
all right so it looks like we need to
grab
these edges and these edges hit t and
we'll kind of bring these guys
in a little bit basically
looks like yeah this comes in just a
touch
and so does
this piece so let me
let me use the actual loop select this
and then hit mo that's going to be our
our move tool
and we want to clone it so i'll just
move this out a little bit and i'll do
the same
here
yep and then let's take these all of
these
points here or these edges rather
and we're gonna scale them in towards
each other
about like that okay and then i want to
let's see i want to i want to bevel
these um let's go symmetry on this
down the middle hit zero
point mode select all that
and we make sure that the gizmo is right
in the middle so i want to push that
gizmo all the way to
plus x
yep there we go and then we'll throw it
into symmetry
all right now i think
i need to break up
these points here i need to bevel these
ms
because it's basically let's see it's
basically like
try to make a cut down this thing
this guy moves over
a lot of trial and error on this thing
you know
get this thing down like this and
um because like this this piece here
almost is in it's in a couple different
polygons so i
i wonder if the way to do this
is to again to follow my own piece of
advice here is to model this thing
flat first and i think that is the way
to go
so i'm going to start with a straight up
polygon
in here holding control i'll make a
polygon
and i'll rotate it 90
and we'll scale it down
and i'm just going to move these points
here so let's take the polygon
make it editable with c
and let's go ahead and like move this
up here this will come up and out this
way
we want symmetry on this
so let's go ahead and bring it up and
out i'm gonna make a cut down the middle
we'll get rid of these points here on
the side
and we want yep that's where it is
symmetry
on the xy awesome okay
so i want to build out this shape here
something like this um
see
something like that
these points can come up a little bit
aztec thank you for the super chat first
time i watched your videos was carbo
warfare holy crap
then you stopped uploading and i found
you on corridor happy for your journey
bro best wishes thank you
yeah man um i can't do it all i can't do
my channel
and rocket jump at the same time i can't
do my channel and corridor at the same
time so
it just made the most sense to dive into
my stuff full time man so i'm so excited
so so excited
all right let's keep going on this
try and get this detail looking nice
move this out a little bit
yeah that feels good to me um maybe
these guys can
come in a little bit man y'all the super
chats are popping off today thank you
fabian uh much appreciated sending some
love from lockdown
london i built a little macro 3d scanner
for insects and your videos helped me so
much in making the scan shine
that's what's up man heck yeah heck yeah
dude
you guys are awesome thank you for uh
for continuing to support me
even if i take a long time to
you know do my stuff in 3d it's like
it's it's it's a lot of pressure i want
to be able to do stuff perfectly but
it's trial and error at the same time
you know there's a lot
a lot to to bounce around in your head
when you're live streaming it's tough
it's tough indeed let's get this shape
we want to get this shape
right so um what is
how are we going to do this ctrl drag
down here um
get this going maybe come out here a
little bit i'm just really trying to get
the shape of this thing correct
boom this one can kind of
come in like that
awesome awesome awesome so this is kind
of
the vibe here on this watering can let's
move up
these points somewhere up here
and let's give this another cut because
i want to
aztec thanks man thank you thank you i
appreciate it
yeah i want to uh
kind of get this you know what would be
fun is actually be able to do some
photoshop where you draw out the points
to build your plan
build your game plan and then go from
there because i feel like this piece
let's see this piece kind of
comes down to the corner like it
currently is
and then you have this piece coming down
here and this piece coming down here
i don't know if that's the best way to
go
something like that maybe
so that is our like flat version
and then we from here we can i'm just
going to duplicate this control drag
so i have this as a backup in case you
know i get all janky on it
and let's go ahead
make it editable so it's one piece now
and i'm gonna grab all these points
control a 31 point selected and hit uo
that's optimize
and again if any of these if this number
went down i mean you had doubled up
polygons
but in our case we're good so i'll
select all these
hit d make sure caps are on and push
that
back
cool
so there's some
3d elements to this that has the
stupidest thing i possibly can say
yeah of course there's three elements to
it um
there's some like inner detail on it you
know what i mean so let's make two
and u l loop selection we'll scale them
[Music]
out a little bit
like that
and then let's go ahead and actually
delete
these guys
and i believe we can delete these guys
and we'll bridge this so m b
we got bridge tool
gamma place yo thank you for the very
generous super chat holy crap that's
amazing
um he says thank you for all the great
content you made
while in corridor and i wish you the
best of luck on your new path you're
awesome man you guys are so cool
thank you thank you for helping me out
here
man i just hope that you guys stick
around and i hope you all learned
something
through this process um and it's and
it's of value to you guys i really
really do
um i i can't thank you all enough for
the support though this is awesome
all right so we're just bridging this
stuff
and following the shape of everything
again go to
point mode select everything hit uo
just to make sure we're all good there
so that's about the shape of that
um moving up into this
piece so this piece let's again we'll
solo this
this piece here is connected on the
right side
so what we want to do
is we can grab all of this we can delete
this
and let's bridge so m b once again all
right
bam we'll get that connected
let's get this front bit connected
okay so there's an end gun situation
here
what we can do is go kl
bam hit those points like that
i think that might solve our issue um
eric dude my goodness thank you thank
you thank you thank you
uh you enjoy my stuff you recently
started your own
uh you recently started your own cg
business and i'm thinking that youtube
could be a good way to get your name out
there and get clients what would you
recommend for someone new to youtube
great question um i would say focus on
the the stuff you do um
sorry by the end of the stream here my
brain starts to lose itself
focus on the stuff you love doing
because you're going to have to do it
consistently
and you're not going to be able to do
stuff that you find
you're not going to do it consistently
all right so you have to keep it with
consistency
you're going to have to do focus on the
stuff that you love
and you're going to try and collaborate
with people that
have a bigger audience than yourself but
you guys speak the same language
um so definitely those three things
right there are going to help you guys
out
a lot when starting your youtube channel
it's a lot that's a lot of work
but um very very doable very possible
you just got to stick with it all right
so these points here
let's bring those guys up a little bit
in fact i'm gonna grab these ones too
and we'll scale those out just a little
bit
awesome okay m b once again
let's get this bridge tool going
boom very nice same on the back side
very nice and now we can take
these points here and
scale them up and in
so i'm going to grab all these points um
in
fact yeah no it's the points get all
these points
up in here and we're gonna open them up
no i lied i lied what do we want
we want to
basically crunch them down
like this
open it up
and
[Music]
we also want to take these back points
here holding
shift to grab all of these
and move them forward
yeah something like that that's gonna
that's very nice i like that a lot
great great hymn thank you thank you for
the super chat i'm glad you like
watching the streams and that you're
learning a ton man that's
that's really where it's at i'm learning
a ton as well
you got to keep learning gotta keep
growing
all right let's get these points move
these guys down
get these points
actually now before i move those down
kind of what i need to do is kind of
grab all of this
hmm i don't want to do this
evolver dude one of the og's good to see
you chris
uh man thank you thank you thank you
yeah i know a photo scan would be
a lot easier enough said
it would be a lot easier
and part of me is like man i probably
should just photo scan it but
i don't know at the same time it's fun
so
it's a good time it's a good time let's
take our our slide tool
mo and make sure that clone is not
checked and we just want to slide these
points down
cool and we can probably open them up a
little bit it's a little intense
and we might as well grab these guys too
and i guess just this one and open them
up as well
so when you go in here and you give it a
subdivision surface
you know you can start making some cuts
and stuff
and really like sharpening
up this model
got your edge flow going really nice
um
yeah so it's just you know a lot of work
to get this thing done
certainly i don't know if we have all
the time
to uh to wrap this thing out because you
know i can only stand for so long i'm
only
i'm only human here
but i don't know maybe maybe on the next
stream or something we can do detail
the details of this which i would really
like to do i'm probably going to work on
it throughout the week
and then show you guys uh some more
details later i can
definitely post stuff on the discord
server um
details and also that's that's a good
way to catch up on all this stuff there
caesar super chats chris super chats
y'all
killing it oh my goodness caesar says
you really enjoyed these troubleshooting
moments in 3d it's only when you
actually get it right when you realize
how much you learned from it
absolutely yeah keep it up and uh and
chris
lidar and photoscan uh seems similar but
accuracy is
a world apart ah interesting the lidar
is using um
i don't even know it shoots points out
right it like shoots out points and like
knows when it stops and it gets it from
all the angles that can perfectly make
the
the photo scan you want to call it a
photo scan
oh man i'm exhausted y'all
i am exhausted
this is really the process let's finish
the low poly version of this at least
okay
i don't want to leave you guys hanging
too much with that so let's see
if we can make a cut here
um we're gonna need to cut along
probably along here and we'll need a cut
along
here as well
and that's going to be how we get this
handle so we can delete
this bit there and this piece
is going to come out
extrude this out here and we want to
make
a right angle so basically
we want to get up in here and see if we
can't
connect this stuff together what's the
best way to do this
using these polygons that we have
all right
it also does a thing too where
hmm these pieces
come in
all right so all of this
we scale this down i want to basically
match what we have on the left side
by scaling that down like that
and then bringing these side pieces in
all this stuff
and scoot that in
okay very nice
now i basically want want or i basically
want what i have on the right
but without this piece so
maybe i delete this bit i think the
easiest honestly the easiest way to do
this
is to probably hit it with symmetry
right here and
boom let's hit it with the xy
um bruno what's up man thanks for the
super chat
you want to say that you've uh you've
abandoned 3d
but i've helped you get back into it
slowly but surely greetings from brazil
dude that's awesome man that's freaking
sweet
uh 3d is so much fun man keep creating
the stuff that you love creighton i love
i love doing it it's like a puzzle to me
that's that's like
my favorite man it's just a big puzzle
so keep it up brother
keep doing your thing man all right so
we want to optimize this
just to make sure all these points we
got 148 selected
hit uo still got 148 so that's good
now again this left side
is the same as the right side except we
want to
we want to delete this bit here
that leaves us with a gap which we can
bridge with
m b
amazing perfect perfect perfect now
there's a handle that's cut out of that
it comes out the middle so we
we want all this to be connected so i'm
gonna go ahead and
make those cuts there in fact
i'm wondering if we can just make it
work by selecting this point
and restrict to selection so we just get
those cuts right there because i'm not
really going to change the angle of this
i'm wondering if we can just do
i'll do the same on this one
kl and i might be wrong you know we
might have to come back later
and change that but i think for now
this is going to be good for us um let's
just restrict it to the selection
right there we'll delete these bits
here and we'll bridge it okay so m
m b once again
awesome so there's your handle on the
side of that thing
artemis what up dude man thank you
for that super chat seriously this is
the most super chats i've ever had on a
live stream
that is amazing you guys are so freaking
cool it's also the most viewers i've
ever had on a live stream so i hope
i hope you all are digging it it sounds
like you are uh artemis says you've been
watching the videos
about how to make my surface
imperfections i learned a lot from it
thanks and keep it up ps weekly
challenges and submitted renders in
there
are really inspiring hello from russia
yeah man you guys have
killed it on this weekly challenge so
much good stuff
and i'm very excited to break that down
with you literally like within the next
five minutes i'm about to just wrap this
thing out
and we'll get right into it um
but artemis i appreciate you thank you
thank you sir
all right yeah this is this is
turning out here let's go ahead and just
make this a little thicker
whoa let's try it again
just a little thicker
and maybe
we just do like this guy
and this guy so just everything minus
the handle
and we open it up just a little bit
i really like the shape of this thing
it's very cool
this is what we have um
and we're very very close the last thing
is the handle on top
it looks like the handle on top uh
kind of tapers a little bit here so
maybe we can grab
these top pieces
move them down
but i want to keep this flat so maybe
that's the move tool
it is the move tool yes
you guys see the difference when i when
i move these polygons down
you're getting this you know the skewing
here
on these faces which are no good i don't
want that i want it to be flat based off
the reference
so i'm using the move tool that's mo
or the edge slide tool sorry mo and i'm
just sliding the edge
and that's maintaining that sharpness
but also giving me that rounded look
that i want
and oh what happened there
okay so it's being a little janky on me
so maybe the way we do it is just select
these guys
one at a time
wow do we really have to do this one at
a time so come down like
negative 1.86 sure that's the number we
want
select that guy
we'll come down i guess this is
1.86
and we'll do the same on this side one
point
negative 1.86
and 1.86
cool that gets everything nice and
neat and since these are flat we can
actually
us i'm assuming we can just cut into
this polygon
right here let's try
uh kl
and we want to restrict it to selection
let's go ahead and
chop one and two
just like that yep and from the bottom
we'll get that piece
and that piece now we just bridge
these two pieces here so
mb the bridge tool you guys remember
let's bridge that bam back the other way
we'll get the top and
yeah we'll sneak in and we'll get the
bottom
right up in there that's your carrying
handle
for that thing um i'm going to bring
these points
in a little bit uh
all these guys just to get the right
shape of this thing
boom that
is the low poly version of this watering
can um the igloo thing we can probably
punch out later
with a boolean or something um
and you know i'm probably i probably
need to come in here and get the
the cap piece but i think it's time to
move on y'all
y'all get the point got a lot a lot of
stuff to do a lot of stuff going on
bam 180 points on this thing that's fun
i dig it that's the like janky
lope or high poly uh version but
it's not sharp and we need to go in and
we need to sharpen those edges
to make it look nice
but that's it that's it y'all
okay guys i think it's time to talk
about
the challenge winners you guys worked
really hard you did a good job
so here's what i'm gonna do i'm gonna
announce these winners the five winners
and i'm going to go over like
30 honorable mentions because there's
just so many good ones
um if you guys didn't make the honorable
mentions list don't worry about it
it's okay um just join the next
challenge okay and
keep learning the whole point of this is
to keep learning all right
and i hope that we can inspire each
other to keep doing that okay
so here's what i'm gonna do um i'm gonna
take a two-minute break
and i'm gonna be back and we're gonna
knock out this weekly challenge i'm also
going to announce
the next weekly challenge for you guys
to get started on at any point
all right so um i'll be right back y'all
enjoy the chill screen i'm about to pop
up right now
i'll see y'all in two minutes don't move
right don't move
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
all right y'all it's about that time
all right we're going to do this we're
going to review some art here all right
this is going to be sweet i'm very
excited to get into this
there are so many oh all right here we
go so
before okay here's the thing here's the
thing here's the thing
before i get into this i must give a
disclaimer
because we had 325 people
join this weekly challenge this week
it's the most we've ever had
on a weekly challenge it is really
freaking cool
with those 325 people though we found
the most
cheaters that we've ever found
combined like with from all the past
cheaters
we've had more than all of the past
years combined
on this challenge right here i think we
had to ban a person or two
um for using downloaded models
for using past projects the point of
this is to learn and grow
so we don't want to just download models
and say hey that's a that's it
really it just comes down to reading the
rules you all just got to read the rules
when we do this thing it's very
important y'all
read the rules all right um
also the reason i called it on friday
um as opposed to saturday at 9 a.m is
because there's just so many i had to go
through it took me hours to
to pick the five winners but this is
something i've been wanting to do for a
while so
the deadline i think it's always going
to be no i don't think
i know it's always going to be friday um
at 9 00 a.m so we're just moving the
deadline back by day it gives me a
chance to go over the winners and
like basically
it makes uh my morning my stream
mornings
a lot easier on me and a lot less
stressful so it's just the time i need
to get that done
um so yeah guys uh read the rules you
have to read the rules i know
like it's a little convoluted but please
read the rules when doing these
challenges
you guys don't want to get banned from
the server you don't want to cheat
whether you're doing it knowingly or
unknowingly we reached out to people
and they still lied and said i didn't do
this i didn't do that but really they
did
guys we got like six or seven moderators
on the server now and they all worked
super hard like around the clock to make
sure that
these submissions were legit so we need
to respect their time
gotta respect my time and respect your
own time right
so with that being said guys i'm amped
alright
there's there's been so many freaking
awesome submissions on this
the majority of you guys like 95 percent
of you guys did it right
um you know you modeled it within a week
by hand
no no uh photo scans or anything like
that all right so let's get into it
the first winner of the weekly challenge
who's gonna win my surface imperfection
pack
as well as all four models from last
week's video the pen the knife the bone
phones and the water bottle
you can do whatever you want with them
it's going to be mr
mdk with this incredible
render of uh wiimotes not wiimotes
they're nintendo switch joy-cons
is what they are and it's perfectly
immaculately
rendered look at these things um
the surface imperfections are top notch
the modeling is top-notch the textures
are top-notch like
this is such a difficult thing to model
i'm blown away and the switch
is basically it's my favorite console i
love it so much
it's the best um you're getting the
lights down and you're actually using
your camera movements
very nicely here they're cinematic
they're clean
they're well done they cross fade into
each other
and it's not jarring it's very pleasing
and i'm enjoying looking at this i could
watch this over and
over and over the only gripe
i have about this mdk and you know this
is that
there's there's just no story it could
it could be sitting on top
of uh i don't know
uh a magazine a gaming magazine or
something
uh it could be i don't know what other
story elements you could put into this
but
maybe just like a small little
environment um to help
you know like what environment would
these joy-cons be in
you know what i mean so that's that's
the only thing i'm like story i think
that's the one thing that you could have
done
to you know 11 out of 10 but you're you
obviously
won the challenge so don't worry dude
i'm very impressed it's absolutely
beautiful
so moving on to our
second winner here we got five they're
in
no particular order okay the second
winner of
the weekly challenge by the way you're
getting a challenge roll on the server
so you're gonna be right up top
people are gonna see all the challenge
winners um every day
all the time on the discord server so
the next one is going to have to be
boom yaw cg mod with this
incredible render and here's what i'm
talking about the story
like you got the story worked into this
a little bit um
it's it's sitting in an environment um
these suitcases there's cobwebs on these
things
um so they're old they hadn't been
opened in a long time
i'm getting to know a little bit about
these
objects based off of the way you're
lighting this thing
based off the environment and mdk i
realized that surface imperfections
do tell a story you know so they're not
super clean these the the controllers
have been used
um but yeah like this is incredible
i i had to check in with all five of
these guys to make sure it was done this
week
by hand and sure enough it was yasi
mod he wins these things pretty
consistently
but my god absolutely incredible render
hats off to you
i think you said that they were like
your grandfather's suitcases or your
suitcases or something
um but that's a that's a darn good
render man
congratulations you are a challenge
winner this week
you're getting all my models and you're
getting my surface imperfection pack
if you don't have it already um so
congratulations to you yasiji mod
hats off and moving on
after i drop the iso on this camera here
a little bright isn't it
well that's not working anyway moving on
all right so we got i am number three
whoop nelly with an incredible render
you got the story going
you got that story going and your your
your model is incredible you got cobwebs
up on this thing
like they've been there for a while and
the birds flying up the hummingbirds
checking it out seeing what's going on
for uh
for a little bit of scale um the shoes
are all dirtied up
modeled by hand within a week
this is absolutely incredible um
[Music]
oh it's perfectly lit it's perfectly
modeled it's perfectly textured
it looks like a photo scan but it's not
it's just what it's really well done
it's really really well done
great use of story great modeling um
you even got some graffiti like a little
bit like a graffiti on the
tip of the shoe there it's so good and
it's so good
hats off to you nelly this is an
incredible render you should be proud
you're getting all four of my models and
the surface imperfection pack
i think this is your the first time
you've won a weekly challenge
so that's exciting that is very exciting
all right moving on to number four
out of five here let's see
here we go bam moonshake 3d
with this incredible render of a camera
now there's a lot of
um camera models that were submitted
that i thought were really well done
very very very well done
this one just happened to be my favorite
it's got the surface surface
imperfections it has the story it's
sitting um
on a magazine photo magazine
that maybe this camera took the pictures
in it
your surface imperfections are amazing
your modeling is amazing it's a very
simple model it looks like but the
detail is there man like
100 percent super super solid model
i'm very impressed moonshake you you do
solid work
um you've won some of these before and
i'm glad that you've won again you're
showing
everyone here what is up this is amazing
something to really look look up to um
so congratulations moonshake you're the
winner this week you got that challenge
winner roll
it's gonna be on the top right in the
discord server everyone's gonna know
everyone's gonna know and be inspired by
your amazing work
and finally the final
winner of this weekly challenge is
but don't click away because i literally
have 30 renders to go through
and show you guys as an honorable
mention because there's so many good
ones
the last winner is
boom wait is this i don't think it's
ronin
i think it's jason bourneveda i'm sorry
i'm i'm messed up the name it's
jasonborn veda let me type that in
now there's just there's a like i said
guys there's a lot to do
there's a lot to do on the weekly
challenge i just missed one of them
jason bournevida uh congratulations
this freaking render is sick man there's
story
there is story in this that's what i'm
talking about
um and your object here is the
the cassette tape and then you got the
speaker in the background
the nice muddy surface but i really dig
this i think is a really nice high
quality detailed model your lighting is
super solid and on point
you got your service imperfections
crushing and you built a story around
your object which is
really really what i'm looking for man i
love the name of it it's the 90s on the
cassette
super sick man congratulations
to you jason you got the challenge
winner roll
you got the freaking surface
imperfections and you got all four
models from last week's stream so now
guys
big congratulations let's get a round of
applause for our winners
and let's get into the honorable
mentions because there are so many good
renders
like i gotta i just gotta show them you
guys did such a good job
so let's break it down here um let's see
let's see
all right let's hide this we got our
winners on the left and let's just go
down the list
first up we got bobby riggs with a
medium format
film camera the surface imperfections
are top-notch let's just get into this
full screen i think this will be like
bam yeah the surface imperfections dude
top-notch super solid i'm i'm loving
everything you got going on here
um your text strings are r yeah sorry
your textures
are really nice and your lighting is
super solid so
congratulations bobby it's looking
really nice
who's next who's next we got akuma with
this really really cool
uh keyboard this is freaking solid man
i love your wood texture that you got
there it's really nice
and you did a really solid job modeling
this keyboard hats off to you
it's very nice good stuff let's get that
full screen see what it looks like
got some nice surface imperfections on
there um
sick man yeah i learned a lot about you
guys too
doing this challenge um there's a lot of
cool video game renders there's music
renders
uh different weapons different objects
and stuff lots of coffee lots of cameras
all right next we got the dread soul
with
a video yes full screen
look how sick this is it's like all
super cinematic for some freaking
clippers it's hilarious um you got your
imperfections on there you got your
bloom and your glow
on there it looks really nice and i just
thought that this was a super solid
model
really good job good work on the like
cross hatching there
you got some animation dude your camera
work
is freaking solid
it's very very cinematic i dig the way
you did this here
um so i wanted to shout you out the
dread soul
congratulations for that honorable
mention you guys
are doing good work next up we got soul
nate
with another video we got a few more
videos for you guys here
let's go full screen on it dude soulnate
is so good
soulmate puts out solid work all the
time and
this is no exception your texturing is
solid for just even like a white object
it's a really solid uh render let's loop
it up
let's loop it again here let's see what
we got look at the surface imperfections
and like the bump specifically the bump
when we get into this close-up here
it's just really nice it's really
detailed
and it's a really really good model so
congrats soul nate
for that honorable mention um y'all are
close y'all are really close
kalepsy is next with the playstation
controller
yes yes yes i love playstation so much
i'm playing through ghost of tsushima
right now but look at this thing
amazing solid solid work fantastic work
um a very difficult model to work on
actually um
it's a really difficult one i think the
only my only gripe with this one
is the camera movement it starts and
stops i
i feel like it should just kind of flow
through the thing you know
um that's really my only gripe other
than
adding surface imperfections but i think
it's solid man really good work
here and i just wanted to shout you out
kalepsy
and jano with this one here this is our
last video
sorry second to last video i love your
cinematic movement here let's
let's take a look in full screen um
you got your surface imperfections
fantastic model there really nice on the
minute and hour hands
and you got some dynamics it looks like
a little bit of dynamics
i love the way you presented it it's
very filmic
it feels very appropriate and it's lit
very well
rendered very well so jano congrats man
on the honorable mention good stuff and
we got uh
bayou bonog bongo
sorry bon you bongo
what an awesome render i remember my ps1
it was my first console
and this one is this is like the mini
right this is like the ps1 mini or
something
it's not the the original ps1
i remember a friend had this one but
dude your stickers are solid
such a good job on that um the
imperfections are really good too but i
just love the way your stickers are all
like broken up and
crusty like that it feels very legit and
ctr dude that was my favorite
game crash team racing really good job
on this
i love how your memory card's kind of
crooked too it's kind of janky and
broken
i love it really good good job on your
textures there
bon uh bayou bongo b-a-y-u-b-o-n-g-o-h
congrats on the honorable mention all
right
zachary with this one here and we
checked
you know we got to check on these
because this is this is an easily
downloadable model that's the thing that
we got ourselves into is we were like
people can just download these models
and say they did it but i checked with
all these guys here
and they did it legit so this is a
really good one
your surface imperfections your lighting
your composition
and your modeling skills boom they're
popping off
it's really good stuff you should be
proud
very very proud zachary um trips
is next look at this look at this look
at the detail
look at that detail it's so good
god it's so good it's like so sharp and
crispy and your
bump is perfect and your your lighting
is perfect
uh fantastic work it's a tough model
it's a tough shape too so i wanted to
shout that one out
trips congratulations man honorable
mention
steve you're next you got a freaking fan
this thing is great your rendering
quality is perfect
your modeling is perfect like what else
what else can i say man
it's really good it's really really good
yeah i love the fan shape it's a good
one it's a very very good
little little model to to bite off there
and get into
um seb is next with the coffee maker
yup hand modeled within the week
congrats for the honorable mention man i
wanted to shout you out i think your
rendering quality is nice
your textures are very good um the the
mugs
seem a little small to me but i don't
know maybe they're tiny
who knows um you got some smoke i think
you said to use photoshop for this theme
but this is super solid man good work
all around
ronin one of our moderators in training
yes yes yes yes man this is so good
the the skin shader what the heck i've
never seen a skin shader that nice with
the hair and everything
but the watch is the focus here it's
very well done
how are you doing the numbers is that
like a photoshop
file with alpha or is that straight up
geometry
with like a radial cloner how are you
doing that that's
pretty sweet yeah i wanted to shout you
out there
one man is next with this one here uh
hand modeled within the week really nice
good job on the car man
that's a really cool really cool model
it's a difficult one too cars are
difficult but
this one is like a little bit more on
the doable side i like it
it feels really fun and you did a good
job making it feel old you had some dust
on it and stuff and you did a good job
with the imperfections
and your your wood floor is great i'm
assuming it's probably
from like bridge or something but uh
solid work
one man very solid all right next up we
got
one dead duck with uh an amazing render
here this one
almost won it was very very close it was
with
in the last little chunk deciding of
which ones are going to win here
and one dead duck puts out constantly
good stuff so this is amazing
your imperfections are great your
modeling skills are great your rendering
is great
like it's just the it's just what it is
guys these are just some solid renders
here for you
next up we have nova with the gamecube
controller
yes i was playing last night with devin
supertramp we were playing smash bros
and we were both on gamecube controllers
uh this this piece of technology has a
very
very soft place in my heart um
so i think it's cool i think he did a
really good job
and my only note would be to get a
little bit closer to that purple color
on the gamecube controller it feels a
little bit washed out but other than
that
i think you did a really good job
getting especially getting getting the
shape of this thing and also getting
the the seam around the controller is
hard to do
so i think that's a really solid render
congratulations on that honorable
mention all right we're moving on guys
we still got more mort bot mort bort
yeah mort bort this is sick hold on
you guys take a look at this i'm gonna
get something i'll be right back
so you know i love it because it's a
good render
honestly like it's a really solid render
the lighting is really good
and it's very well done but i just gotta
show you all something
i got a little something in here
boom right here right here this is it
got one of these i got
one of these and i got one of these i
got three of these unopened packs right
here
unopened and i got the fossil ones too
so i don't know man i don't know
a fun fact fun fact i never got a
holographic charizard
and i bought some packs and gave him out
his birthday presents one year
and i kept some for myself obviously um
one pack i actually opened the one pack
i opened
i got a holographic charizard i've never
had one
as a kid growing up um but
it happened to happen i guess i don't
know i got lucky
but this one's cool man mort bourt
congratulations i dig it solid render
leventy yeah what a good render
super solid model very good render
quality good lighting
good presentation against the background
if you're gonna do it against a solid
color
that's the way you do it a little bit of
uh dynamics in the background give it
some reflection
bump up the roughness good stuff man uh
super solid
cosmi is next this one is good like this
this one really has the uh that filmic
light to it um and
the model is really solid it's a really
cool
piece of uh it's a really cool shape
really
and your textures are spot on really
good work there so congratulations for
that
honorable mention josh close is next
with another guitar
dude your rendering is solid you're
modeling it's all
just everything it's just everything
guys
these renders are really popping off and
there's so many of them
there are there's so many of them we're
like halfway through
all right let's keep going josh close
congrats man
um boshel mig
bashil mig look at this this freaking
thing
dude look how good this looks let me get
the full screen on this thing
just move it around here like the
textures on it oh my god
this one almost won this one came
this one came pretty close um
absolutely incredible very very nice
model there
uh you should be very very proud boshel
mig
yeah the textures are perfect the
modeling is perfect i got nothing else
to say
jd reach with the gun this is graham
pappy's gun
um that you hand modeled within the week
textured within the week
amazing work very very solid um it's a
difficult shape
but it's doable it's doable like it's
cylinders and flat pieces and stuff
and you did a really good job doing it
and you lit it very well too
so really nice work there we got um
frosh
frosh electro frosh electro
this one's cool i like this you didn't
just put the helmet
on the ground you you know duplicated
the helmets all around and
they're actually not clipping into each
other either so you probably hand
placed all these or you did it with
dynamics
but it's really well done the rendering
quality is amazing and
the texturing and of course the modeling
is really nice so
frosh electro congrats man that one's
amazing i dig it
we got folio next with this awesome
knife render
really good job here let's get up in
close
um let's see let's freaking full screen
having a full screen
you know i'm just making it i'm just
making it happen here we go boom yeah
look at that isn't that nice you got the
surface imperfections
really good shape there really good job
on the knife
i mean probably better than my knife to
be honest
yeah you're even getting in there with
the uh the like
beveled out extruded out hole and
everything really good
even on these guys solid work
very solid work there moving on we got
fatu edward
this is crazy this one is really nice
let's go full screen with this one and
see what we can see
let's get it up here boom
look at that isn't that nice
like that's a sweet model and it's a
difficult model to do
so congrats on that honorable mention i
think this is
solid work here um
big fan of this one very very big fan of
this one your texturing game is really
nice i think it could just use some
imperfections
get in there with the dust scratches a
little bit and you'll be off to the
races
david k another another camera render
here this one's really nice
you're up in here with the with the
imperfections you got the faded font and
text and stuff you got
little speckles of dust on the on the
lens
very good work very very good work there
david you should be proud
i dig it i love the colors too man
aryan sv with this chair
look at this chair it is like really
really well done
the shape is a little tricky maybe on
the handles there
the armchair um
but man your textures and your lighting
freaking a level man
a plus very good work ariane sv
we got andre on andrej
next up with these headphones these
headphones
look how good this is look at freaking
how good this is isn't that crazy
they even have like the dusty little
hair pieces and the
the scratched up rubbery
foamy plastic i feel like i can
i can touch this one it's so good
it's so good congratulations andrej
that's a-n-d-r-e-j
freaking killer absolutely killer
zak 4k is next let's go full screen on
this
this is a pencil sharpener i guess i
think
um super sick work man your
imperfections are killer
you're modeling and texturing is killer
you're rendering and lighting
everything is spot on keep it up man
like you guys
there's so many good ones here keep up
this good work all right you guys are
gonna win these things seriously
um if you're making the honorable
mention you guys are very close
moving on we got victor guevara with
this one he actually
did a fun uh breakdown of this on
his youtube channel i don't have the
name of it here but if you you know go
in the discord
and you find this render here victor
guevara's g-u-e-v-a-r-a
um he did some cool stuff i watched it
and like actually learned a little
little thing or two watching his his
breakdown
very very cool render there we got the
game factory with this one
this one's really nice look at that uh
the lighting is killer
modeling is killer uh presentation is
amazing like
you got a few object objects here that
you're presenting
um man so freaking cool you put a lot of
work into this one
and it is a plus work this was another
one that came very close to winning
very very close tesla
rock yeah this one was another one that
came super close to winning
i love it your imperfections are solid
your rendering your lighting your
modeling is all so good
you should be very proud of this render
this is this is just fun watching all
this stuff man it's it is so good
beautiful absolutely beautiful seven
seven gunt this render is
sick man very cool stuff
um modeled from scratch this week
every single item here on this list and
it's presented very well i like your top
down look
and i like the way you lit it it's
really good stuff man
super solid seven gunt congratulations
on that honorable mention we got
solder vidsen
solda vinson sold of ensign yeah
this one's cool it's a record player i
love record players i got one myself i
got a few records as well
uh it's not just a a vanity record
player
and i'm sure that solda modeled this
based off of
his record player as well so this is
really good i like the
stickers on this thing i just think the
the only thing that's a little intense
is
the surface imperfection on the plastic
glass it's a little intense
um but other than that i think it's a
solid render
next up x or mxb
with this uh coffee i don't know i don't
drink too much coffee what do you call
this
coffee pourer thingy um
that's amazing you did a really good job
rendering the glass here and lighting
this glass it's hard to do
and your textures are ridiculous
fantastic work
mxb you should be very proud
all right we got like eight more to go
morticus this is a good one this is a
really good one
it is simple yet not simple
at the same time there's a lot of little
pieces going on here a lot of little
intertwining parts
and channels and grooves that cut
through this graphics card that make it
difficult
uh your texturing and your rendering is
a hundred percent man
with this one i can see why you didn't
use surface imperfections
um you know it's a it's a showcase
you're showing off a new product and i
think it really worked out
mr wasabi with the harry potter lego
this one
is solid i love this one so
much um the imperfections are ridiculous
let's go in for a closer look here
and like let's just go full screen on
this thing let's get up in here
look at this it's so good
the imperfections are really killer and
the modeling is really good you did a
solid job here
um it's really well done that's off to
you
yeah mr wasabi congratulations
manuel k this one dude okay this one
almost won
this one almost one let's go full screen
um
it's so good let's look at look at the
details on this
it's incredible like the game boy stuff
is really nostalgic for me obviously
because i'm a huge gamer
um and nintendo happens to be my
favorite company when it comes to making
games
um they're just the best and i've wanted
to do
a game boy render actually for a while
so
this might just be the inspiration i
need to do it but
man your imperfections are insane your
modeling skills are really good
and i am blown away by this one
congratulations
you should be so proud
j yoon with the calculator this is
another hard one
look at this look how difficult this is
this model is crazy the surface
imperfections are great
the texturing the quality like dude this
could be in any pixar movie this could
if you composite it well enough it could
be in any any short film or
literally anything this could be real
for all we know um
but your modeling skills on this are
ridiculous
absolutely ridiculous june
926 congratulations
and finally we got one last one
and it's a three for boom
caesar lg with
the freaking sticks uh
this is awesome super old school you got
a couple different angles on this thing
i really dig it your surface
imperfections are killer you got the
fingerprints up on here
it makes perfect sense your textures are
solid your lighting is solid
everything is so good so
man that that is it y'all that concludes
all these renders holy crap there's so
many good ones
i'm really proud of you guys keep up the
good work keep up these challenges let's
keep these things awesome
you guys have set the bar from here boom
way up to here
you've raised it and uh you're gonna
have to
you're gonna have to show yourselves
again this week because we got to come
up with another weekly challenge
right now all right so
i'm open to suggestions if you guys want
to start leaving suggestions for weekly
challenges
i'm open to it we're going to figure it
out
right now all right so what are we going
to do
um for this week we got space um
landscape among us food
machines black and white ghibli
fluid sim weapons nintendo
all you metrics okay i'm gonna go and
just like pick two or three
and then we're gonna do a poll okay
we're gonna do a straw poll
hmm so many lots of ones we've done
before
video game i think we've done video game
before
um star wars we did
ah this is a tough one okay yeah this is
when this this is when the chat pops off
world war ii interesting galaxy
all right uh universe ocean
and we did underwater once tanks
um
let's see neon we did neon
astronaut i refuse to do astronaut too
many astronauts out there
um computers ah interesting interesting
dark souls i love dark souls yes
racing okay okay
um ball interesting a fantasy themed
galaxy hello kitty electronics
um janky vehicles
that's funny
lots of good lots of good suggestions
here
black and white we've done black and
white
power rangers that's fun gears
uh what if we did something like uh
like the inside of a clock tower like uh
cogs and gears maybe steampunk have we
done steampunk yet
oh golden hour dude that's a good one
mdk golden hour
that's pretty good i like that that'll
get you guys working on your lighting
get some good lighting going
um
samurai or ninja maybe we could try
samurai
down for golden hour or samurai maybe we
do
one more samurai
golden hour um
ai could be interesting
all right i'm gonna make a straw poll
real quick for y'all
um and let's let's
basically leave this to a poll
all right straw poll
let's do
weekly challenge what do we want to do
weekly challenge we're going to vote for
it you guys are going to figure out what
you want to do all right so we have
uh golden hour
we have samurai
and one more what do we want to do
hmm
post apocalypse there's a lot of post
apocalypse
steampunk okay steampunk fine
let's do it so we have golden hour
we have samurai and we have steampunk
so let's see i'm gonna send you guys a
link
no more suggestions i want you guys to
be able to catch this link go to this
link and and hit this vote okay
so here we go um allow okay let's create
this poll
and let's share this thing copy the url
all right no more chats because here's
the link go here
and let's see what we can get here
see what we can see
all right guys the uh the results
they're gonna be coming in right
what do you all want to do this week
for the weekly challenge we got golden
hour we got samurai
and we got steampunk these are all
things that that i could get down on for
sure
so let's see let's get these uh let's
get these votes in
here we go steampunk is
taking the lead 41 percent
uh y'all don't want to do golden hour i
see how it is
i think uh i think
the world has spoken here do you guys
let's try one more time
ah okay maybe don't show the poll on the
screen it influences the votes
can't see when you vote well steampunk
it looks like is winning
a little too late steampunk shot up to
the top so
it looks like we're gonna be doing
steampunk that's gonna be
the weekly challenge this week y'all so
steampunk it is
you can make it a steampunk samurai i
don't care you can make it a steampunk
samurai at golden hour
it could be all three but that is the
challenge is steampunk for this
week that means you need to make a
render within this week
due by friday at 9am it's got to be a
steampunk
themed render okay a steampunk themed
render you got to read the weekly
challenge that means you guys can't
copy sorry i'm saying a million things
at once
read the rules they're in the discord
okay
you can't copy a tutorial and post that
tutorial as your result
it'll get you freaking kicked bake
something original okay make something
original
um it could be as little as a steampunk
item or it could be as big as a
steampunk scene steampunk world whatever
you want
obviously don't plagiarize people's
stuff you'll get banned um
[Music]
yeah the submissions get cut off friday
9 a.m
gaming wizard thank you for the super
chat appreciate you man
heck yeah but i mean that's about it
y'all
that's about it i'm happy to answer
any questions here is kit bashing okay
yes kit bashing is okay but really
try to um do what you can within the
week you know
again the point is to learn and grow
dang this scene is all blown out
i think for whatever reason my my iso
wheel can't access it from back here
but that's okay that's okay
all right guys i got about five more
minutes
i'm gonna chill i'm gonna drink some
water
i'm gonna answer any questions you guys
have about the weekly challenge
uh yes you can use whatever program you
want
but i'm here to answer any questions you
guys have about me personally
about the weekly challenge or whatever
this stream has been
the most successful stream i've ever
done since i started about a year ago so
thank you so much guys for making that a
thing
thank you for all the super chats thank
you for the support thank you for
subscribing for following
and for learning a thing or two with me
i really appreciate you guys
um and and definitely if you guys can
click that skillshare link in the
description down here
get your two two weeks free of
skillshare and get your learn on it
helps
me out um and helps me do more of this
stuff it makes it
financially possible to do this so
i appreciate y'all um where do you
submit you submit your weekly challenge
on the um the discord server in the
submissions channel
now there's a link to the discord server
in the description below
i hear it's broken though so maybe go to
one of my other videos and click the
discord link
in in that video it'll be in the
description
max how's the nft game going man i just
posted the one
um and i i want to make more i i want to
make more
uh it is a huge way for me to be able to
financially justify
uh you know doing all of this stuff as a
job
because i have to make my own money now
um which is difficult
so i get as much as i put in so yeah the
nft thing is certainly something that
i'll be
i'll be working on uh tesla rock what do
i do
if i get creative block um
go for a walk do a workout get your mind
out of
the path it's on because obviously it's
not working it's hitting a wall right
so try and sidestep do something a
little different
um that's very helpful for me
take a take a break yeah take a break
from your thing
i also have these uh
let me show you something
so i mentioned brian eno before he's the
guy
he's a u2's producer he made the windows
startup sound
he's also an ambient artist he's the
godfather of ambient music so i have
these uh
these cards by brian eno and peter
schmidt
and they're called oblique strategies
over 100 worthwhile dilemmas
and it's just a stack of cards
that each have a suggestion on it
um this one's called this one says use
unqualified people make something
implied
more definite and they're just random
suggestions
retrace your steps you know whatever
that means to you when you're working
ask people to work against
their better judgment um
don't be afraid of things because
they're easy to do that's a good one
that is a god i need i need that one
i make everything difficult on myself
i'm putting that one at the top
so they're uh they were made for uh all
these guys were in a band together
and they would have these cards to help
them like get out of creative blocks
there are oblique strategies by brian
eno and peter schmidt
pretty cool i think there's a free
version online
what are your thoughts on vr being used
in making 3d models i think it'll stick
around
i don't know it's just another tool to
get things done
i think it could be a pretty sweet way
to do things if it helps you then it
helps you
i have yet to really get in and make
something in 3d with vr modeling
but yeah it could be very fun
henry what is something uh you between
c4d work
any external inspiration uh what do i do
between super dwork
i love drumming i love drumming
it is a huge way for me to take a break
and relax
i also really enjoy playing video games
and i love cooking
i love doing yoga i love rock climbing i
love traveling
i love photography um
watching movies is great uh what else
man
so much i love going to the farmer's
market but i hate shopping god i hate
shopping
but i love the farmers market simon
jones what's my favorite eno album
and why is it music for airports
that's my second favorite one my first
favorite is thursday afternoon
thursday afternoon is an hour-long
ambient song
and it's basically the best thing ever
just look up thursday afternoon by brian
eno
and it's basically the most peaceful
thing you'll ever listen to music for
airports is also good
uh the first song on that album is my
favorite
um unreal or c4d for a newcomer super
interested in 3d but have no experience
unreal is deep man so like all the stuff
you can do in
c4d is like a fraction of what you can
do in unreal
because unreal is made for video games
you can make games
within there you can make animatics cg
stuff you can make it look real
it's free unreal is free but it's a deep
dive
it's a deep dive but they have a lot of
educational tutorial stuff for you to
get into
c4d is not free but
if you want something just focused on
like 3d
and stuff then i would say blender go
for blender it's it's free
it's a good time uh can you tell us
where you get free textures yeah you can
get uh textures on texturehaven.com
um i think there's a site called coo
textures
c-o-o is like uh a legal thing it's like
uh you a legal usage term c-o-o
c zero zero i think is what it's called
um just look up c-o-o textures or
c-zero-zero textures
but texturehaven.com is probably the
best place
yeah cco sorry yeah yeah cco
creative commons means you can use it
for free
for anything i believe
have i ever wanted to visit the uk
absolutely i was there
in birmingham for a convention
up there uh i forget the name of the
convention it's like a gaming convention
up in birmingham um
yeah i love traveling traveling is
basically the best thing ever so
trying to do it as much as i can and i'm
very sad that i haven't been able to do
it as much because of
you know kovid hopefully that'll
that'll change soon render warrior you
bought my
imperfection pack thank you so much yeah
and you find it useful that
i hope so i really hope so i put a lot
of work into those things
i'm glad you guys are using them that's
freaking cool
um have i been standing the whole stream
yes i have been standing the whole
stream
it's uh it's a lot it is a lot but i've
been doing it
have i ever visited canada yes i've been
to
calgary to visit my good friend joel
gardner
i've been to um
i have been to toronto to visit my good
friend young lee
and then we went up to montrealt to a
ski resort and we learned how to
snowboard well he taught me how to
snowboard
i love canada i want to go to vancouver
next that's on my list
what i think of interstellar i thought
it was fine i think inception is better
yeah what's my favorite part of japan um
i think the culture shock and
the culture uh the people are so nice
especially the tourists people are very
nice to tourists people very loving and
kind
um accommodating the food is killer the
sushi the ramen oh my god
and the sense of adventure and just the
newness you know it breaks up
the the everyday life for me
here in the u.s which i think is boring
we have like no history here it's all
just like we're so young but you go to
japan you go to china
and there's just like thousands of years
of history so
i'm such a fan i'm learning japanese
currently um been doing it for about a
year
a little over a year so hopefully next
time i go to japan which will be my
third time
i can speak the language and get around
you know
have i been to hawaii yeah i've been in
hawaii twice
once with uh my parents when i was
little
and the second time was with devin
supertramp we filmed a far cry
3 video um that you can find on his
channel
far cry we did like a far cry i think it
was far cry 3. it was either two or
three
um and that was an amazing trip like we
had boats on the river
and like we were doing jam sessions with
all the locals
um like he knows a lot of the locals
there if you guys don't know devin
supertramp he's like
one of the biggest travel adventure
youtubers out there
ah man my back hurts y'all
my back hurts i might have to end it
here
appreciate you guys thank you so much
for joining me get on that weekly
challenge okay
we are doing what are we doing steampunk
that's what we're doing
get on that discord the links in the
description if the link doesn't work
which i hear it doesn't
i'm gonna you know just go to go to last
week's video and click that one
so i got a lot to do here i gotta post
challenge winners
i got to um update the description here
i gotta update the thumbnail maybe
um i gotta make sure the ads are running
and all that stuff
so i got a lot to do before i recall it
a day so
guys thank you so much for your time
thanks for joining me and
you guys will be here next week right
subscribe if you're not get the
notifications
i'll see you next year on the live
next here god i've lost my mind at the
end of this thing
i'll see you next week on the live
stream okay guys
you all have a good one i'm gonna call
it
peace out y'all love you thanks for the
support
later guys